I'll play the upbeat music
doesn't seem appropriate today
um
welcome obviously it is Friday
September 23rd
and uh usually Fridays are
happier days
uh so as you guys can tell
I'm trying to be serious but okay
as you guys can tell from the title
there was
um something happened between uh me and
Ila
I don't know how to say this but there
was some infidelity
on my part
and uh things are not good right now
she's uh she took the kids and she's
moved out
uh she's got she's living nearby but she
just got a little rental place until we
figure this out but
I just want to say like we never we
didn't like have sex I just want to say
that like
it was
more of an emotional connection we had
which I understand is cheating all the
same
you know emotional cheating but
there was some physical contact
ultimately but like we did not have sex
and I
I know it doesn't matter necessarily but
I just want to
say that for the record
but I [ __ ] up I don't know what
happened man I lost 15 pounds and all of
a sudden I'm so [ __ ] full of myself
it makes me sick
[Music]
honestly I'm so disgusted with myself
how I've been behaved and I just I'm so
sorry to ELA I've absolutely taken a
match to my whole [ __ ] life
disgusting shut the [ __ ] up Rudy I'm
being serious
I don't know yeah so obviously
on Wednesday
um I did exchange a kiss
with um
young gravy
stop why are you doing a scratcher what
was this fresh and Fit Stop dude
please being serious
uh here is me and uh grave I don't wanna
I don't want to watch it but I think
as the title says Ethan does not want
this video online
that's a good title Love
they didn't really get any views though
Did It ultimately don't you think Ethan
kissing young gravy Ethan making out
with a young gravy would get more
hmm I'll try that
um
yeah so here's what happened essentially
[Music]
oh my God you guys what what is this
it's uh great for socials
and you know shame on you baby I mean
you really like you're a [ __ ] friend
bro it's good for socials I'm not taking
the blame on this one can't do it bro
like I'm sorry but I expect you to have
my back a little bit you go it's good
for social I was I was amazing I was
making a joke finally you understand me
no clearly not because I still did it so
I'm saying you finally heard me and you
did what I said I didn't understand it
though because you don't [ __ ] speak
straight
yeah well it didn't get through to me
because you're [ __ ] now all of a
sudden I start listening to you you want
me to start listening to you I did have
you [ __ ] ruined my life you [ __ ]
shame on you bro
[ __ ] what do you do you go to a
bachelor party with like you're the best
man you go oh it'd be funny for socials
if you [ __ ] up stripper
you know what good friend it makes you
feel better blaming me for this then go
ahead
just go ahead Ethan I know it's my fault
I'm just saying like damn friends like
these
put my arm around you big fat kiss and
just a peck right no tongue yeah but
you're looking at me so intimately bro
don't treat me like one of your MILFs
you guys can't see his hands on my leg
it's not even on camera
you know treat me like one of your males
you kiss me like a milk oh gosh
[Music]
soft lips are you even gave me one of
them yeah yeah and I don't know when I
went home and told you I I wanted her to
hear about it before anyone else
obviously and what the thing that you
didn't see is that his hand was on my
leg under the table shame
and things did escalate
out of sight
and I have to say that I did like it so
that's what scared me the most
and I just don't know I don't know Ela
when I got home we had a fight
I tried to convince her to stay but
ultimately she moved out she took the
kids and I am my life is [ __ ] over
oh look who's here
[Music]
she still has a job to do though so
come on
[Music]
I'll be professional and fill in
my obligations
to the sponsors do we even have sponsors
no no
no he even tweeted it out I mean he this
is a declaration of love
and I'm very I'm very sorry please take
me back
you know what
um was the most problematic for me I've
never seen you so like shy and giggly no
no I'm telling you it's like I'm being
honest with you there was there was
something there and that's why I feel so
bad about it
you were so you're like blushing and
like
it was interesting
interesting even Arab world news did a
report on it he said Ela responds
harshly after Ethan's betrayal here
um how do you get that footage actually
not sure what this is this is uh it's a
sandal she's throwing a sandal at you oh
Middle Eastern Style
[Music]
I wish that's all that would happen
hmm
him
so ultimately we're just gonna have to
do the show
I just wonder like
um
we'll just we'll just do like tiger
belly we'll sleep in the same bed we'll
do the show together
and uh right
can we still do you think they still
sleep together I don't think they said
they don't
but
I have no idea okay I'm not just saying
like maybe not exactly like them
I think that maybe I need to go on some
other podcaster and kiss to make it even
no
absolutely not that is crossing the line
it's only fair it's only fair it's only
fair absolutely not that's a hard veto
I'm sorry but I'll take the kids and
leave
take the kids back from your ass
Barbershop
anyway uh obviously I guess you know uh
uh the gig is up here uh we are doing a
goof because today
arm segment is
click bait Olympics H3 podcast we're
going to be doing a tier list of our
favorite H3 H3 uh click bait moments got
you [ __ ]
hey throw your hands up got two
[ __ ] you believe me psych
psych that's a good actor I did actually
kiss young gravy though
okay let's go
that's a big big Psych in your face
[Music]
uh hey Gabe hold on one sec buddy yes so
we're having a really fun segment coming
up
clickbait to your list there's actually
we've done this a lot and they're really
funny okay cool I actually didn't really
feel upset I just I hope that everybody
understands it was cute
did it turn you on no I just thought I
thought you were very cute just saying
by the way I have uh my gamer sub today
is black cherry
the best one yet really really sorry
again one sec what flavor you got
whoa waifu candy oh my God wait try this
one you like that one or is it intense
black cherry dude I love this yeah black
cherry wife always is very
it's a waifu yeah it is a waifu hey Gabe
what's going on buddy you're at this
you're at the park huh
buddy are you by yourself there
I'm by myself yeah you getting any
stairs
no stairs okay yeah I mean usually a
grown man by himself at a park
these days anyway maybe there was a time
when that was fine but oh that's back in
the days back in the days huh
I'm swing it's just kids
um what the [ __ ] is going on my dude
what's up this this weekend
it's Friday baby
it's Friday baby oh
[ __ ] my opinion bitching butthole
push-ups oh you're doing push-ups
doing some push-ups setups trying to
lose some weight baby just like me bro
[ __ ] yeah hey how many push-ups can you
do
I can do 10 15 10 15. that's good yeah
that's not bad
what about sit-ups
maybe yeah
maybe like 10 10 yeah I mean those
aren't easy especially when you got like
I know from my fat ass I'm not gonna
make uh judgments on your body but it's
hard for me to even
you know sit up I'll tell you something
Gabe I've lost like 16 pounds and wow
thank you and last night
last night I was cutting my toenails
and I I know and it's embarrassing to
admit this but before I lost the weight
it was really hard for me to bend over
and cut my nails thank you my toenails
and so and so last night when I was
cutting my toenails it felt a lot easier
you know so wow yeah
yeah good job thanks man are you able to
cut your toenails or do you struggle
pretty yeah pretty easy I'm not I'm not
overweight but yeah you're not as fat as
me yeah
any plans this weekend
I'm just just doing some push-ups and oh
that's so yeah okay that's it all right
after that it's gonna crash
cool man all right I love that
all right
sick
what else is going on at that Park their
families and stuff
no luckily I'm by myself
oh yeah Gabe uh well I have you here
yeah [ __ ] me [ __ ] yeah
oh
[ __ ] in my armpit and tits in my butt
[ __ ] that's my best [ __ ]
sorry about your dad passing away hey
I'm ready
I wanted to ask you about this video
though while I've got you because
you go to a chiropractor
well I went to one um Dr gold Dr G it's
like one of the best chiropractors in um
north um I think it's Chatsworth oh he's
the best he's the best chiropractor
wow that's a huge claim to fame what's
the population of Chatsworth like ten
thousand uh yeah right probably around
that that's pretty impressive
was this your first time seeing him
oh I've seen him a few times okay here
and there
was trying to do yeah what did he tell
you
he told me you know watch my calorie
intake
um you know do the bike not the
treadmill and
squeezy on the salt he probably he's
saying if you're having back pain the
weight loss is going to help you right
yeah yeah exactly
let's watch this
hey I'm here with my man Dr Jeeps
getting my back adjusted my back's all
messed up baby
[Music]
so he crack it he's cracking the back
right he just rolls
he just rolls your ass over he buckles
you he's body slams you do you ever
wonder do you ever sit in there and
you're like what the hell is this guy
even doing this can't be real
um it's it's really just gonna you gotta
trust one you gotta believe it yeah I
just gotta believe they're pretty good
if you have like a back problem or
muscle problem he cracks it and you feel
much good it's not a scam you feel
better afterwards
I feel much better really
how long
until the next time I see him I guess
yeah let's keep watching how that works
I want to see a manhandle you gave
here he goes
here it goes Jesus oh my God
so I'm here working with my man Gabe and
uh worked on his fine got him an
adjustment and he feels better we have
some things we're going to help him out
with his health but uh he's in great
shape and we're gonna get him in better
shape better shape
was he down to be in the video with you
he was totally cool about it
that's cool about it he wants he wanted
a video like to promote his business oh
he's trying to get oh he's trying to get
promotion so wait did yeah did he get
like a clients and stuff did he charge
you for that
that's nice
did he ask you not to curse
yeah
I'm embarrassed
man that's just who you are though yeah
like that's the personality you know
what you should tell them adjust my
butthole [ __ ]
butthole adjust these [ __ ] tits
you know everybody has a butthole that's
true hey
everybody
that's what the [ __ ] is true
that's [ __ ] that's true truest thing I
ever said man actually that's actually
not true there's a video of a girl I saw
she had her butthole removed I'm not
joking for some medical necessity had
her butthole removed so actually Gabe
put a little small asterisk next to that
statement
I swear it's a thing look a fact checked
me
yeah
probably a bag colostomy bag shit's in a
bag I can't pronounce it which kind of
seems nice in a weird way that you don't
have to work I mean I know I know it's
like not but not having to [ __ ] or piss
that's kind of Fire
right something just comes with a bag
also you have to carry them never have
to wake up in the middle of the night to
pee
um
wearing a colostomy bag is not yeah
I know I'm just saying [ __ ] maybe fire
you've got like a really fire back to
put it in well I think you I think you
keep it under your clothes because it's
full well maybe we can find you a doctor
decorate it all cute you can do an
elective uh what is it to me proctectomy
proctectomy is a surgery to remove all
or part of the rectum wow that's an
elective well I'm saying maybe we can
find a doctor to do it elect for fun
exactly
and then can I open it back up Ethan
Klein gets his [ __ ] removed now
that's the title right there all right
Gabe listen
it's always a pleasure butthole
um oh you know and also I just want to
thank you for that wonderful Cameo you
sent our friend yeah oh that was so
touching and moving uh when you said I
mean I was just sorry about your dad
passing away
yeah it was great they loved it so
you're the man Gabe oh it's a pleasure
appreciate it
have a good weekend okay dude lots of
push-ups and sit-ups all right
all right
yeah baby [ __ ] yeah
[Music]
oh
okay there's kids in the background I'm
gonna hang up
Gabe white clock game everybody
good I gotta say this black cherry is so
I love it this is insane y'all gotta try
that black cherry it's about to be my
flavor I'm about to take it I switched
to yours so good right
I'm about to make this that the H3
flavor
um
[Music]
watching Dave do the chiropractor thing
we talk so much [ __ ] about chiropractors
on the show at this point is it maybe
time to go do a little on the scene uh
Chiropractic segment Ethan gets an
adjustment well
listen I would like to I don't want to
show up in someone's office and just be
a total dick though you know what I mean
no you can just do it just go through it
and see Becca you know get first-hand
experience I won't like criticize him
while it's happening just go for it sure
I know a guy you know I don't have back
pain I'm gonna go to the chiropractor
and leave with back pain yeah yeah
that's what happens like I don't have
back pain why would I don't want to [ __ ]
with that yeah maybe it's a bad idea
then
I'm in pain
um anyway got a great show here Ela how
are you how's your week been how do you
do
good good talk to me baby I'm like
Curtis all right
okay
how are you doing I know I know
can I get a shout out to my pal Danny
buns and the small pecker Society well
yeah I'll have you know that I've been a
member my whole life
card carrying what is that the small
pecker Society yeah
um so I hear some announcement at the
top of the show we're going to be
uploading members videos now on Tuesday
which means that for members we will be
having a video every day of the week
five days a week so look forward on
Tuesday's members
next week you'll be get to see me and
gravy making out from even more angles
oh no here we are sharing a Glizzy wait
there were more angles you didn't tell
me about that you have to be a member
yeah is not that there's more angles
there's more than one incident yeah
that's what I mean yeah so this is a
sneak peek of the BTS on Tuesday for
members kiss but now we're eating
quizzes you're good with the glitz yeah
let me see
[Music]
oh wow
oh no good
busy
just microwaved it it's good every time
this is you can't go wrong
that's so good thank you by the way I've
been dieting hard so that Glizzy hit me
like a [ __ ] like a wave of euphoria
yeah you've been doing so good thank you
it's awesome
that's
every time before we always laugh the we
jinx it so I try not to say too much but
it's really awesome I don't know like I
see such a difference I don't know if
it's because like the Wellbutrin takes a
couple months to like kick in
but like one day I just started and like
it's I've just been able to control my
my hunger cravings and I've been able to
stay motivated to be exercising every
day
and um it just it doesn't feel that hard
to me right now but I don't want to jinx
it there's a hunger there is a hunger
and what's good I'm still like eating
food I enjoy because what I'll do a lot
of times if I know I want to get down
and dirty in the evening is I'll just
have like a tiny tiny meal
for breakfast no snacking and then I can
Crush like a thousand calories
1200 calories at dinner
I see you even like um
mortaring
stuff that are not going to be the worst
you know when we order out or yes so
I've been avoiding carbs not because of
diet or keto or anything but because I'm
trying to avoid my blood sugar spiking
because I'm afraid I might be
pre-diabetic so that helps me and I
think keeping your blood sugar low is
overall really good for your body and
your digestion and stuff and I think I
have been feeling better from keeping my
blood sugar from going crazy and
um you know what else what I've been
doing I have met Metamucil which is
basilium husk that's the secret sauce I
take a whole lot I do this before every
meal I take a whole glass
put two massive Scoops in it
I drink a whole glass of of Metamucil
fiber before every meal again I get full
I Stay full
it's a life hack you know what I'm
saying it's a vibe
what's up Todd G
oh [ __ ] before you love me and the
words of Mike Tyson
he added a slur afterwards which I'm not
going to add of course
um
Ethan is the sweat still a major issue
you know what is the what they said is
the sweat still a major issue of belt
Wellbutrin it actually has gotten better
it's so interesting yeah yeah I felt bad
for Ethan because I was like Well he
seems like he likes being on it but like
is he gonna have to sweat like that
forever now because it was like it was
not unreal it was unhuman yeah but it's
a little more than usual but it's
actually like totally fine now yeah it's
kind of interesting so it's all looking
pretty good
and I mean uh
uh tater tots are crying and [ __ ]
right now because what are they gonna
say about me once I'm once I'm a skinny
Legend yeah I know
oh
you know
everybody leads with he's so fat and
gross
tell us more about Metamucil oh you want
to know more about Metamucil I'll talk
about it all day
it's like a miracle [ __ ] dude well okay
so they have it in pills they have it in
biscuits like cookies and then they have
the raw powder now it's a bulk
forming
uh
fiber supplement it's super interesting
if you put scoops of it in a glass
and you don't chug it it gets so thick
grumpy it gets it turns into like a
sludge and it's actually very
interesting that's great you want that
to happen in your stomach
so before I was taking the pills and
they're just so small it's you're
supposed to take like 20 a day I [ __ ]
you not on the back they're big and
they're huge yeah you said they're so
small
I mean they're so small compared to yeah
they're they're small compared to the
powder supplements yes but they're big
but they're big pills that are really
annoying to take yes so um
those weren't really working for me you
know
and so I got back on the Metamucil
powder supplement and then you can just
go [ __ ] crazy with the scooping but
my shits are Immaculate obviously and
what's interesting when I'm doing a
really good dieting and
I'm at a good calorie deficit
I almost don't [ __ ] at all isn't that
crazy I have like infrequent and Tiny
shits because my body's using everything
there is that's interesting when I lost
a ton of weight in college it was the
same thing I would [ __ ] like once every
three days a tiny little nug what I know
it's crazy that's what it is
I use it all
right my body's dead and we need it all
[ __ ] dude
hmm damn it's black cherry
yeah and also there's other things I've
been doing that helps like oh yeah
oh this is my uh this has been Ethan's
icon on WhatsApp
communicate uh off the air since I've
started profile picture oh but Metamucil
I love that it regulates your blood
sugar level
and it lowers cholesterol as well if you
take it regularly
um I was just gonna say that I love that
anybody that talks to you not from the
podcast like from Teddy fresh they also
see this oh [ __ ] I should change that
probably when I was first well anyone
that saves your number just in there
yeah whatsoever oh really yeah when they
go to Whatsapp you'll automatically
appear so yeah they need to pay me dude
when I started talking to you I thought
I was getting catfish because I met a
mutual catfish
maybe I'll change it then don't change
it you think it's of the vibe all right
I'm not a useful but yeah I love
Metamucil I think it's great another
thing that's actually been helping me
I'll eat around six or seven and then
I'm done I close down shop for food and
I [ __ ] done and one thing that helps
me I've been chewing a lot of nicotine
gum and I'm not going to recommend
people do that because like if you if
you don't have any reason to start using
nicotine then don't do it but the gum
actually
because I get the satisfaction of
chewing having something sweet and also
nicotine's a opposite appetite
repressant so you know that's helped a
lot drinking lots of uh no sugar drinks
sodium pops and uh stuff like that and
you know my Cravings have been very
manageable
um it's kind of been surprised it's it's
so far so good so I'm trying to turn I'm
trying to go all the way I've seen Ethan
do it so many times before like years
ago whenever he would decide to do a
diet it could really do it and commit
and then it's been like all the last few
years that just for some reason you
weren't able to and I think probably
most likely the Alexa Pro obviously oh
for sure but so it's really cool I'm I'm
just happy for you to finally see that
you're seeing results because I've seen
you get disappointed so many times you
know I was trying to feel it's
impossible yeah and I blame myself I get
super hard like every night before bed I
would just think about like oh I [ __ ]
up today
I ate too much I'm a [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] I'm never gonna lose weight
there's something about the Lexapro that
like like you said I always had whenever
I got a little too much weight I always
was able to control it yeah
but since I start Alexa Pro I just I
lost all of my control of my impulse it
was so weird I couldn't stop
it's very weird because it doesn't
manifest itself in any other way in life
no except for the food yeah no not
really and so
um
so that that was really [ __ ] with my
head and I gained 70 pounds man so I
don't know the Wellbutrin I I think it's
it's helping I'm assuming I don't know
but uh anyway I'm Gonna Keep it going
yeah Philly D is no okay let's see
because everyone says I look skinny you
know
it's hard to see it on yourself right
it's hard it's like
so let's see here it's become my little
parents massive bro here this wasn't
that long ago right or how long ago like
April 20 days ago wait they call me
skinny Legend here oh
I've been dieting for that long
well they're just using that oh 20 day
of this post this was posted 20 days ago
yeah that 20 days ago was that the
Pokeman was on wait so how long have I
even doing this diet well that photo
with
um yeah idubbbz and Anisa was like the
week before I got home so end of May
oh I was pushing that thing out it's
actually it's probably end of April
because May was greater clash and this
was before no way I've been dieting that
long no you weren't
I think I've only been doing it really
really recently for like a month yeah
I sent another screenshot so yeah show
me show me I want to see all the skinny
Legend stuff because it's impossible to
see you know this was the episode where
I really noticed
oh that's crazy this I feel like I'm
stretched out though there might be some
slight warping but even so
that looks good
loving that
there's something we can do about the
face just in general
there's nothing wrong with the face okay
okay just saying
I'm gonna be getting some fillers here
pretty soon
construction then I'll look like Zac
Efron like I'll look like Zac Efron
that's awesome
you know who would have thought by the
way thank you for the gifted
um we got a couple gifted in here gift
gift flow oh gift
20 gifted from prolapse penguin thank
you so much there was another one maybe
you guys can just link it in Discord
because there was a five I thanked them
in the church yeah
thank you for the
donut what was their name Blanca I
believe Blanca Blanca Hawkins Blanca
Hopkins
yo this is gonna be me in uh about three
months Ela no I'll look just like him
I'll get lift I'll get no because once
everything gets filled by the way did
you guys talk about him because yeah
people got mad at me I was going I was I
may be too mean about it
[Applause]
yeah but I I don't think you'll be as
mean as me no no just because I saw that
he says that he didn't get any plastic
surgery that's what I'm saying see look
they all start to look the same so I'll
I'll be a member of their uh Community
yeah
who's that on the left no clue
is that a Rodrigo Alves also known as
the human Ken doll he's a famous like
plastic surgery addict I guess here
Eli's looking exceptionally beautiful
today and seeing lots of comments thank
you
I
because Ethan said that he liked when I
had blonde hair and I did too I decided
I'm gonna go back next week
yeah and I'm gonna go short again
[Applause]
let's go I was like today I'm gonna go
the opposite I love that look on you
dude thank you so good my favorite Ela
look maybe ever really yeah dude it was
it was popping it was fun
um speaking of popping and fun
teddyfresh.com new collection just
dropped super fun super exciting you see
this teddy bear head there 100
recyclable we are going to try to do
this more frequently like because we
work a year in advance so whatever I'm
working on now like you guys don't see
until a year later but so as things
progress you'll start seeing maybe one
or two every month that are like made of
recycled content or has a sustainable
story we're really making it like a push
now within the company
um so nice though
I love this car again or yeah just like
been wearing it a while
and then this t-shirt also came out I
believe now
with the
little bit Yeah Yeah
who's wearing uh who's wearing oh yeah
uh Olivia's got that beautiful cardigan
which sold out actually the first thing
it's so cool it's really nice anyone
else pop him
I don't but I had requested the uh the
one that you were wearing the other day
oh this one they're gonna water airbrush
tie-dye yeah I think that one's so cool
I was gonna wear it today of course I
forgot it at home Sam is wearing the Sam
is looking sharp and the don't hurt my
feelings to you the original art by you
will climb
kind of a shame you can't see her full
body though because
I like the whole look we'll get out here
okay stand up Sam
it doesn't it doesn't show well well
well uh let's get a camera then well
well I don't think I don't know if you
can oh yeah there we go here
this is Sam
Samantha looking fabulous and her she's
got black boots throw those up yes yes
Queen Slay Slay Slay hairstyle
[Applause]
oh which one the Pug oh yeah show that
off because this one Noble Knight love
it's a pug it's how do you call that
technique
it's a patchwork applique oh Patchwork
applique my Noble Knight it's wonderful
cute little socks
this is my favorite piece again this is
kind of like our special thing here
I've never seen tie-dye like this
super beautiful it's super unique and uh
it's absolutely beautiful there's this
one too which is like stunning in my
opinion I love that one yeah it's so
nice this is my fave
and
um that's it there's a lot more stuff
but at the very bottom that one's really
cute I like this one a lot
so yeah which one maybe not a piece I
just want to say is thank you guys for
putting us on the website that was
really cool I didn't know oh yeah yeah
at the bottom of the website oh thank
you guys for for taking the photos I
love it oh we love it that was an
awesome uh photo shoot we're gonna do
salmon Ian nice okay okay
love it um also we did a little artist
collab in this collection with
um if you just grow up a tiny bit here I
go okay Brian blomer yeah he's a really
cool artist yeah I love his art and um
yeah so there's a few pieces with his
commissioned artwork that he did his art
is awesome yeah this this is all the uh
the designs he made yeah super talented
artists want to give him a shout out
love showcasing a really cool talented
artist Brian
bomber blomer
uh check them out super talented
by me as hell
[Music]
I love this one yeah this illustration
is so sick
the kind of doctor Sue says okay right
definitely very
[Music]
very vibing on that but there it is
teddyfresh.com check it out there's all
kinds of good stuff there
yeah all right um
oh yeah there's one other thing I wanted
to say someone said uh
anesthesia shave thank you for the
gifted what hello I don't sorry you guys
know I'm not the best at pronouncing
[ __ ]
Ola the September collection is so far I
bought over 10 items yesterday really
can't wait to take pictures of them
peace thank you also she's going to see
Zach live at the Troubadour let's go
by the way Zach's birthday was yesterday
happy birthday thank you happy birthday
thank you did you have a good birthday
do anything special yeah I went over to
uh the folks for dinner and um I think
we're gonna celebrate more this weekend
but um yeah it was a good night yeah
did you um
you guys just kind of hang out you got
what are you gonna do on the weekend
um well tonight we are going to
celebrate Ally's birthday
um
yes
and then Saturday I'm spending the day
with Sean Paul and
then Sunday my grandmother's coming in
town
man is coming
give it up for Grandma
uh ladies and gentlemen can we get her
on the phones act sure I want to talk to
your Nano
yeah um actually speaking of live shows
another I know there's a lot of tough
stuff at the top of the show here
our tickets are going to go on sale
pre-sale pretty soon here oh next Friday
for members no no next Wednesday for
members oh okay so this coming Wednesday
correct
members will have the opportunity the
first chance to buy tickets to the first
live show we've done in over two three
years four years four four years yeah
basically the other one was like not
even the podcast as people know it today
I feel like yeah oh it's a very
different yeah that was in the in the
first generation podcast yeah version
one which wasn't a good version it was
on okay it was okay it was a good
version it was a little rocky
it had to be Rocky to be smooth icy
dicey it was dicey
and I just want to say
this is a nice way of saying thank you
to our members because I think there's
750 tickets so I a little more than that
but I don't think there's a lot of
tickets so
there's a good chance that the members
will scoop them all up
so members you will get your first shot
here on Wednesday and then it will open
to everybody else on Friday
I'm sorry to people who aren't members
but uh we don't have many perks for them
so I want to treat them where I can
there you go so uh but we'll see if
there's any tickets for people asking
for information about date and where it
is and everything that will all be
announced on Wednesday as well so all in
La obviously it's in La yeah we should
say it's in it but it's going to be so
much fun we had so much fun the last
time we did it I want to do it make it
into a semi-regular thing it's going to
be our last show of the Year this year
yeah and um also say the purchase of the
tickets we're going to go to a good
cause all the profits from the ticket
sales are going to the crew oh I didn't
know yes yeah you guys are welcome thank
you thank you thank you very welcome
you're very welcome thank you thank you
thank you thank you yeah of course uh so
so
um so that's exciting too so win-win
people helping people
all right when we so there you go that's
everything huh oh and uh people are
asking if it's going to be streamed yes
you'll be able to watch it from home
that's the beauty that's why no one
doesn't like us we're [ __ ] live
from the studio that's why last time was
so stressful we did that we didn't we
did it all we did it all and we're doing
it all again
we'll be better I think last time we
probably lost money
but this time we're selling we there was
only 300 tickets so this time at least
we're selling enough tickets to where we
have like a budget to hire a product or
like a product a touring company and
we're gonna have people like that are
going to help us film it right Dan
uh yeah we're gonna yeah we're gonna
bring in some outside uh crew members so
that um they can operate cameras and
everything so that we're not doing that
so we can be a part of the show as we
normally are yes
yes exactly and last time it was just
for you guys you too and then Dan and
Ian that was nuts that was a while oh
man that's crazy yeah it was a small
venue it was really fun though but yeah
that's fine so yeah that we're looking
forward to uh to that very very exciting
uh Zach
um speaking of your birthday we got a
special message from one of your faves
oh really I know we've been working hard
we've been working Round the Clock to
secure it's hard to get a gift for you
the man has a Rolex already I mean I was
gonna buy you a Rolex bro but uh I
already got one oh you know they say
two's better than one but you know
listen your dream is accomplished
yeah but like who's the your favorite
person let's say that you would want a
cameo from or not even a cameo we pulled
strings this is off time meal favorite
person to get um probably Dave Grohl
Dave Grohl yeah probably Dave Grohl well
well are you ready
here is a big surprise
[Music]
oh my God oh my God oh my gosh
[Music]
oh we got the Hebrew something
[Music]
damn
[Music]
okay
the thing is wow Jimmy always yeah
and uh there's actually one other thing
here for Zach's birthday uh what's your
age 25 25 all yours a cake with a
special message on the top front there
yeah if we can just get a shot it's
you could just read it out yeah maybe
just show it to the people
you want to read it Zach
[Music]
yeah good wow
Zach Lewis live in the Troubadour
January 13th let's go
wow we miss it sweet thank you so much
it's an ice cream cake I understand oh
are you gonna be having some with me
I'll be taking us yeah I'll be taking a
hit of it wow thank you so much it's
very sweet happy birthday thank you for
the birthday
thank you thank you very much
live a true Bird yeah uh Jimmy is this
he's just incredible multi-talented guy
he was kind of impressive yes he uh
he'll call me and just uh
play that like why he'll be like name a
tune Zach we like the same songs
what's that well
um he used to send me pert to my
personal email videos of him
playing a song with his own lyrics but
it was copyrighted so I could never show
it on the show oh yeah I think I
remember you saying that yeah but he's
actually really talented guy and what
can you do about it yeah also so do one
more thing so happy birthday thank you
thank you very much there's one other
thing I wanted to just briefly talk
about before we get into the Nitty
Gritty meaty mushy of the show
yesterday on leftovers we had a great
episode we talked about
a lot of the drama that happened on
Twitch
including the story of a twitch streamer
named delinity
a lot of people were assuming that I
didn't talk to her ahead of time and
thought that I was using her story to
like get at get at someone and so
I did want to make clear that we
actually talked a lot before then
and um
she she gave me the permission to do
this segment
she was afraid that some bad people were
gonna uh
dog pile on her and so she was afraid to
talk about it and unfortunately that is
what happened these guys are such
[ __ ] scumbags and alinity has just
been dogpiled in the whole history of
the internet you know it's just been
[ __ ] up and they're still doing it now
and I feel I feel horrible honestly it's
ugh it just makes me feel sad and so I
wanted to just say guys go send some
love and support to alinity to make sure
that she doesn't what happens to her
last time doesn't happen to her again
where nobody's [ __ ] supporting her
and a bunch of pieces of [ __ ] are just
[ __ ] lying about her when she's
actually the victim of sexual harassment
so just send some love to alinity
and support uh because uh
I want her to know that people do
support her yeah and that's all I want
to say about that it sucks for her how
things always um I don't know why people
just love to
to [ __ ] on her like you said well well
train has a vested interest and
delegitimizing and destroying her
character as much as possible
that's basically all I'll say about that
and he's friends with everybody
for somehow people are still friends
with that guy
but there it is wlinity awinity
[Applause]
but I mean like no matter what you think
if you're like oh she shouldn't have
like thrown her cat or something which
personally I think was a that drama was
a little overblown I mean I don't have a
cat but from what I understand
it's not the biggest thing in the deal
we don't need to rehash this I'm not
trying to bring I'm just saying no
matter what you think I personally uh
don't but remember what you think she
doesn't deserve to be [ __ ]
dogpiled like what happened to her in
the past that's it
she doesn't deserve to be harassed and
humiliated and called a liar
I mean that's it
so we support we stand she sure is and
support
yeah there it is
but you know there was like there was
two separate things one was like the cat
thing which I I get people like years
ago and it was just overblown out of
proportion yeah and that was a keemstar
thing he was selling shirts with her on
it also it doesn't justify dog piling on
her after she shared her story well
people were well people were like
calling
um
like the police trying to get her cats
taken away yeah I just mean the two
situations are completely oh yeah they
are completely like this does not
justify this absolutely well people go
well oh you were part of that dog pal
because and by the way if you go back
and watch our Clips we're always very
supportive of her
even during the CAT thing we were like
the reaction of this is [ __ ]
ridiculous I never commented on the
train thing but I want people to know
that those are two separate [ __ ]
issues okay not if they're not even
connected in the slightest bit
um and the way that people reacted to
her her statement against train if you
go look at the comments on her tweet I
haven't [ __ ] dude sick I'm scared
messed up
so anyway we support we stand and uh it
was Brave of her to talk to me and even
to say you know you can do this segment
uh because uh
it did it did blow back on her and I
feel very sorry about that but there it
is
uh here it is and here we go let's do
the show
um
so what is this one
oh that's just your new favorite what
was picture of UAB yeah yeah I respond
to every I don't know why every single
tweet I just respond because it's just
such a good photo yeah I love him AV
sent in our crew chat a few days ago he
sent this screenshot and was like when
you tell Ethan you don't like a photo
but this is this is not an attack on you
and that isn't the real and now I
appreciate you using this version I'm
okay with this version this one's funny
but this one's just so funny and I mean
you know you this one shouldn't make you
feel bad right no no I like this yeah
yeah we have the one where somebody put
Ethan's face on that yeah that one I
don't like yeah
we're gonna have to uh put a ban on that
one interesting if you can pull it up
yeah we'll show it once and once only
then it will be uh scrubbed from the
internet are you throwing it in uh right
now yeah I'm just grabbing it for my
favorites
[Music]
without further Ado it is I think I
looked kind of tight
oh my God
I think it's fire I look like
a badass wrestler trailer park trash
that's us fused no he you know who he
looks like Dan is one of the American
males
you know oh that old wrestler well he
already looked like that one right and
then this just really remember
unfortunately we can't play it which
sucks because it's the [ __ ] funniest
video ever but we got claimed when we
did but the that wrestling promo from
the 90s the American males I don't
remember it here you'll recognize the
picture because people
posted on Twitter replies all the time
but I'm down with this I like it these
guys know oh yeah that guy looks just
like me
I tweeted out a photo and it trips
people out they go totally is that Ethan
that's an uncle or something wait so
that this one is not Photoshop not
edited at all oh God yeah yeah I've seen
that now that's messed up it's crazy
she's like me dude I always thought it
was Photoshop no that's what he looks
like
I didn't even realize no that's because
she look real is it just this angle or
does he look like me like in the actual
video it's much less so in the American
there's just something about this yeah
it's like that's you yeah that's you in
six months are you ready yeah keep up
the diet yeah see he doesn't look like
yeah it's just in that one photo for
something I think it's the eyes and
maybe the the brow line or something
about the mouth yeah it's the way that
it's like does that one look like me no
I see it
more in this one but less than the other
like the way he's holding his face kind
of yeah
long lost Uncle that's awesome I that
guy's just swagged out bro I'll take it
yeah he [ __ ] it that's an American male
right there Eat Your Heart Out Andrew
Tate
it's so sad we can't play the video it's
the [ __ ] funniest thing I guess you
need the music the music is what it's
all about yeah oh Ethan you should go
blonde with Ela oh yo let's go I'm gonna
cut my hair we'll take the colons I'm
down I always like doing that stuff
thank you Sam I'll take a Time the
smaller I mean I just oh mama chocolate
cake I love Zach's birthday thank you
very much for the cake guys I do
appreciate it
oh mama
wow hi Eva my wife and I are having our
first baby will there ever be a Teddy
fresh release for babies kids
um the only reason we haven't done it is
because I don't know how many of our
audience has reached that age where they
have babies
for it to be like you know a substantial
amount
but we might I I obviously know a lot
about it now have an experienced two
boys so
anyway good luck with the baby talk to
me baby talk to me baby
someone take this away from you
okay we could just share one if you guys
don't let go okay yeah I'm saying I can
I can share it I'm just gonna give a
shout out to Sam for always I know you
know she bought this one but always
bringing desserts and I found out Ian
bakes now too Ian brought a good dessert
earlier this week you know it was
busting yeah thank you shout out Sam
shout out to Sam
they also brought in some leftover uh
Cooter charcuterie board that was quite
tasty
sharing with the office
I only learned that word kind of
recently and I love saying it
charcuterie charcuterie
yeah before we get to the main segment
I just love these posts man there's like
people have been posting text messages
or this one's a clip from a subreddit I
don't know what the context was but it
seems like all my haters seem to think
that uh
I'm just too fat to like I love this
stuff it's very interesting and so funny
it is very important you're not supposed
to write that you know what I mean
you're not supposed to write I hate him
because he's fat you're supposed to keep
that too yeah when did that become like
a thing that people do when they have
nothing else on you I just before that
I'm fat here I'll read this bro he
changed the entire format of his content
migrated to the opposite side of the
political spectrum and became borderline
radicalized there he gains 90 pounds and
became so noticeably spite-filled I'll
have you know I've been spite filled did
you you claim you're a fan have you not
seen my old videos bro yeah I've been
running on spite my whole life
bitter and hateful that's just because
you now like the people that I'm
[ __ ] on yeah that's why it feels
better now and it's now awkward to watch
him fumbling around his words while he
goes on another rage-fueled rant about
something he hasn't researched or even
understands on a superficial level
that's not new either
yeah exactly thank you Dan thank you for
standing up for me buddy
he's the exact type of person he used to
be critical of that's it Mr old straight
from the straight from Israel H3
I get that he has made some positive
changes in how he sees the world
and that's great but that simply doesn't
outweigh the other negative changes to
what is HOAs
to
I don't know what hos is what's in the
con what is the context do you see it
other negative changes oh it's just yeah
there's his yeah I wasn't sure okay okay
uh personality no matter how hard is
weird barely stable fans oh don't go
after the fans try to guess my people
into thinking he does
there it is man
we hate the fatties
that reply is so funny though
but the reply yeah I agree even though
he's grown as a person advocates for uh
women's trans lgq rights calls out bad
behavior takes responsibilities for his
action provides dozens or hours
entertainment content every week and
it's one of the only honest people on
the internet it just simply doesn't
outweigh the fact that he's fat that's
so [ __ ] true man so true well I'm
working on it thank you by the way the
sweet Consciousness you know I gotta say
thank you to our fans I love you guys
you guys really have my back sometimes
um when I see comments like this and
it's nice to see because
the perception people have of me like
the Fallen fan thing is just so weird
also how am I radicalized
how does he think you migrated to the
opposite side of the political Spectrum
yeah again you've always said the same
stuff like and we've always been
transparent about it I think so we have
I mean I've been a lot more open about
it like obviously in the past year
maturing and becoming a grown up and an
adult you obviously start to talk more
about politics like that's just I mean
we weren't
when we were in our 20s in Israel right
out of college talking less about
politics
just like part of growing up but you've
never been like on the other side you've
never like
you were on the other side I say it
become more woke maybe uh after doing
Frenemies just because like I started
interacting with a lot of people that
were never in my audience and I came
something I'm very grateful to programs
that I think I matured a lot in terms of
a lot of issues that I was blind to
right like I mean just in general I
don't think I was like transphobic but I
was but I became a lot more aware of the
issues surrounding that about like uh
you know chauvinism about the homophobia
about uh
or something else but in general it just
became a lot more I think
educated and sensitive to those issues
which is which I think is really
important and I'm very very happy with
that development
but um I've always been a lib you know
I've said it a thousand times I just I
always [ __ ]
dreamed of ridding all these Crowder
fans that were watching me I always
hated these people
who would spam on my Joey salads videos
you know this one's true yeah about like
black people beating up the Trump car
you know what I mean uh
yeah so there it is uh thank you for the
gifted fairly stable fan oh yeah thank
you for the gift and for my barely
stable and 50 subs thank you thank you
the shoddy Prince
yeah exactly Ashley said haters will say
Ethan is a snowflake and it's just him
having empathy yeah yeah
um
so moving on we've got more oh you had
more Jordan petersonship bro I love it
well he's a lot more he's my fave I
don't know what's going on with him but
he started getting into Political
commentary no
like people are starting to ask him
about like his opinion on global warming
and now here people are asking about his
opinion on the roar in Ukraine I'm like
[ __ ] why are you even talking
about this
do they know that your brain is
basically mush from
being pumped with like
formaldehyde the carrier
oh you're a benzo addiction I don't know
whatever they pumped in your blood over
there in Ukraine or in Russia but listen
to this steak man it's so deep so deep
here we go everybody else than anyone
thinks you know the notion that he's
Hitler or Stella and that's just foolish
I don't see any evidence for that at all
I mean first of all Hitler and Stalin
were very sorry he's talking about Putin
he's saying Putin is not Hitler I
remember a tweet you guys could pull up
were you called David Trudeau a Nazi or
a Hitler so let's hear this straight
Justin Trudeau is Hitler
but but yeah but Putin is not Hitler
facts that's what's up dude
yeah Justin Trudeau well he's a lot more
like everybody else than anyone thinks
you know the notion well he's a human
Okay so he's Hitler is Stella and that's
just foolish I don't see any evidence
for that at all I mean first of all
Hitler and stellen were very singular
types and there's a bit of Hitler and
stellen and everyone so you know there's
some truth and not maybe there's more in
the typical Russian language really
there's more than a bit he gets so
[ __ ] serious he's like [ __ ] what did
you just say to me did you just
challenge me I love that I think I think
there's more than a bit in you dude
good here we went from like smiling to
like because you know what's the problem
with him
any pushback he perceives as like an
existential threat now like he requires
pure kiss assory at all times otherwise
he shuts down
everyone really
there's more than a bit there's more
than a more than a bit some say Hitler
was reincarnated in my body there's more
than a bit
it's amazing too that the person giving
the pushback is Pierce Morgan who is a
total [ __ ] [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] as
well but even for him he's like wait
what hey yeah he's got he's got credit
he hosted AGT you know he was a judge on
there oh that's right I do love that you
really want to go on the record with
that
there's a little Hitler in all of us
guys remember
what does that mean exactly there's more
than a bit like like okay
really there's more than a bit really
oh absolutely yeah well why would have
not seism spread the way it did you know
people think well that's all top down
it's not top down
there's there's a part of people that
are all these people who informed on
Kate Burleson well didn't go but didn't
gobble say that the way to get vast
numbers of people to go along with what
you want to do is to terrify them yeah
well that you can hold a grip of Terror
over them oh yeah but in a way that's
what puget's not doing with the Russian
people where he's going back now into a
position of they're all trying to get us
they want to attack us yeah they want to
take us over he's terrifying his people
to Rally support for what at the moment
is a conflict he has started which is
not going the way he assumed well the
most well
you say the wisest commentators on
totalitarian States like like Soldier
netsu
and many psychological commentators
young was a good example of that of
course everything's about young yeah but
I love this Title Here Peterson there's
a bit of Hitler and all of us wait did
they actually put that on the Chiron
it's right here
oh that's [ __ ] awesome
producer in the back like instantly was
like there's a bit of Hitler in everyone
right sure there's more down in bed I
mean what is that what is he trying to
say he's trying to be so deep he's just
saying that like all humans have a
capacity for evil oh absolutely and that
people like yeah in in Germany lots of
people fell in line but um I can't
believe I'm seeing this but Pierce
Morgan had an excellent rebuttal to that
which is that lots of people went along
with it because it was a it was a regime
that was enforced with Terror
essentially he just could they literally
shot people in the streets right and or
yeah and ship people off deported them
to death camps like there are reasons
that people you know went along with it
that weren't just that they were all had
a little Hitler in them you know
yeah I hate that I have to give Pierce
Morgan a w no he's right but yeah he's
got a good point there well I even him
he's like oh yes yes he'll learn all of
us yes go on doctor
well don't you hate Jews people Morgan
that's all I mean everybody hates Jews
at least a little bit the Jews and don't
get me started on those gypsies
you can't trust them
Absolutely I'll tell you what man uh
boy there's a little Hitler and every
single one of us
and even more specifically the Jews oh
no I could just spit on a Jew right now
not kill them that's too far just break
their windows they're never and everyone
shop break their shop Windows hit their
hit or never hit their neck
is there is this worth watching what at
the moment
why why are we elevating this man he's
not smart
and he has no qualification he didn't
really come back with anything like
Pierce Morgan like you said that kind of
made a good point and he's like whoa
yeah
anyway yeah uh here is actually uh he
has a life-size cut out of Hitler he
keeps in his no it's just his little
Hitler coming out oh okay oh I was
trying I was trying to do interpret it
as best I could because I like that
scene in Spaceballs you know where he
orders the soup and the thing comes out
of him
it's a little Hitler in all of us
there's more than a bit literally I have
a tiny Hitler living in my chest cavity
oh man I love it though he's one of the
most entertaining [ __ ] out
there
the Jews
can't wait for his stand-up Netflix
special yeah absolutely
yeah froggy Peterson there ladies and
gentlemen a little Hitler and all of us
yes sir that's his next children's book
oh I love that for a title
kids don't be afraid of the impulse to
kill ma'am and destroy those feelings
are only natural
when you view another group of people as
lesser it's only natural to want to lock
them up in a ghetto and systematically
commit genocide on them
I'm not saying it's right
but it's normal to think about
I think about it all the time hit with
those damn liberals Hitler I wish we
could put them all in a train and say
bye bye Hitler
I'd like to put Ethan Klein in an oven
not because he's Jewish but because he's
awful
lot he took down my podcast episodes
let's burn in
the mob the mob so don't be afraid
children when you go to sleep at night
and have dreams of bodies burning on
fire
every night
you dream of thousands of corpses piled
on top of one another the ash of human
bodies raining down on the snow-covered
fields around you Ian are you cutting
around all of us to show us
disinterested in that he is yeah don't
worry Dan yeah he sure is I can see
and as the children fall to the soot
covered snow to do snow angels in the
ash
of desecrated human corpse
and you wake up with an erection
just know that's normal because there's
a little Hitler in all of us
thank you
uh because I will tell you guys whenever
I listen to the show whenever I listen
to the show and you start going on about
Jordan Peterson it's my favorite my
favorite okay that's why I know you said
that that's why I never get enough these
guys are trying to get me off she's the
most important audience member it's true
cheap manipulation thanks for your cheap
manipulation
foreign
this [ __ ] suffers and that's normal to
want
have you ever had a wallet made of human
flesh
ouchy human leather is a fantastic
object it's durable can we get a dragon
flexible by clicking delete and it's
normal to want that Bella Simmons thank
you for the 50 gifted thank you so much
for that thank you for the gifted yeah
what were you asking for you though and
dragon and Pinocchio can we get some
Dragon Optics here please and some
Pinocchio
are you talking for me and then when
sometimes I dream of a dragon with a
swastika and I wonder is it really that
much different from one meant poke and
Tokyo Paul Geppetto I want to be a real
boy into
I always think about that and I wake up
and say it's normal to be to want to
kill Jews Pinocchio
thank you uh anesthetic Haze for
correcting oh my God my pronunciation
hello but they
read the rest of the
anesthetic Haze but I change it to
anesthetic shave just because that made
my life okay there you go so I was right
I preempted it thank you Godfather also
see you Zach at the Troubadour January
let's go
we be plugging
how we all feel inside
Pinocchio no this is my this is my real
imagination of Pinocchio he's got a
little Hitler in him just like all of us
oh uh did you know wait no I gotta
interrupt you because this is actually
really important I guess I didn't get a
heads up hey hey B
put down the switch for a second oh
what's up did you send C ma'am the zoom
link I did okay because he's in the
lobby oh my God stop everything
c-man is in the [ __ ] Lobby this
is the most VIP guest you cannot imagine
a harder we have had top level
celebrities nobody is harder to get than
c-man bring him on immediately while
we've got him okay holy [ __ ] this is
such a treasure such a such a treat
wow I just happened to glance over and
it's exciting
see man as you guys know he is an
Enthusiast for male feet and uh we had a
really great call with him in the past
he's just been a terrific character we
love him he's an unabashed foot lover
and we we love that about him it's
pretty good you know what I'm gonna pee
before this interview because I want to
make sure also can we do it at the same
time I need to be comfortable for this I
need to be at the top of my game yeah
let's go
see man if you can hear me just stand by
for a minute we're just uh uh taking a
quick restroom break and then we're
gonna get to you that's okay my God I'm
sorry I took what happened last week it
was a mess oh I heard that yeah the the
place you were at didn't have uh days in
in St Petersburg Florida and apparently
um it was bad storms and I got in four
o'clock without some actors who are for
we were doing our video shoot in um the
next day for our wrestling right and
apparently uh they were next hotel over
and then I had to go so excuse me I have
to leave for a half hour they go why I'm
like you're supposed to do auditions and
then the power went out oh okay yeah
Ethan I think Ethan wants to ask you
about that yeah Ethan's gonna have a lot
of questions about that so just uh
that's good for just a minute he just
ran into the restroom so uh are we live
now we are live yes we're live see man
you ever play Super Smash Brothers the
video game no I don't oh okay no I don't
I don't really play video games but hey
I want to do a shout out to the state
Pennsylvania I love Pennsylvania hey
everybody I also like Arizona PA maybe
or Arizona wait Arizona you say oh
interesting like I like Arizona too I'm
trying to get to Arizona one of these
days it's just the time the warm weather
and Florida too so I love Florida what
are your thoughts on um have you ever
been to either of the Dakotas like North
or South Dakota no I'd like to go to
South Dakota
freaking snow I can't stand oh yeah
yeah up in the up in the midwest but I
love scenery I just love nature and I
just think it's amazing how beautiful
South Dakota is and people in New York
are just so like they're like they look
at you like how would you go to South
Dakota it's like I thought people
looking like I'm nuts I'm like why not
you know yeah why you just go to Jersey
people in New York go to Jersey in
Florida all the time it's like there's
more life than New Jersey New Jersey ew
I'm sorry but ill
come on you're gonna you're gonna offend
a certain someone
I like the Jersey they like our little
brothers you know I mean the Jersey is
kind of important things but you know
hey why not I'm a New Yorker you can't
help everywhere I go everyone can hold
on here's Ethan I just got back glad to
see you it's been so long oh my God you
you're aged a lot oh yeah I'm sure
yeah I know 70 now no kidding
he just turned 40s it's been away it's
been a hard year it's been a hard year
for me or two for me as well my god
um well listen you're a hard man to get
a hold of uh you were at last time or
was it last week we were about to have
you on yeah but you were attending a um
foot warship event is that right yeah my
foot worship wrestling that I was trying
to get the videos for because I have a
ring that I'm renting in St Petersburg
Florida it's smaller Warehouse so I got
a bunch of people that would come down
one actor bailed on me I mean he came
down by plane and picked him up and then
never showed up
let me ask you this do you think he got
cold feet no no pun intentions
[Music]
21. you know you claim my love for the
big foot fetish and then then you want
to act he's like well it's good it's
wrestling it's pretty hot and then you
know you don't show up and you're in the
same hotels as me like two doors down
when I got the hotel rooms and you don't
even and you just vanished when I went
to Dunkin Donuts next door to come back
to get everybody coffee and then look
what happens is gone like no one knew
what the hell they went I'm like what a
cow was he the star yeah a coward
because he a coward because he he he was
afraid of participating in his this deep
desire
like white towers texting me like I'm
gonna be part of this is great I really
love feet I want to get I said I'm a
startup well we'll get go and we'll you
know get the business really big and a
lot of guys at the field to make this
awesome and it was great and it was
myself this other guy I met from law
Long Island New York who I just started
being friends last three weeks I he
actually wanted to come down and I made
him worship my feet which was good I
mean he washed up your feet yeah yeah
the boys are strange you gotta
understand I'm a silly boy
although Long Island's different
National and Suffolk I mean it's like
you know it's hard to say all lame can I
ask you I want to ask you do you usually
worship feet or are your feet usually I
like both yeah I like both black guys
like both too but in the wrestling
matches you kind of have to do both
because the way I do it is you lose one
you win one because you don't want it to
be when you're selling videos the same
person always
you want to make these videos awesome
and sell them you know you really want
to make it like it can't be the same
winner I mean it looks dumb so it is so
we had to shoot on Saturday in the
warehouse and it was really hot but I'm
sorry I couldn't do it Friday because I
had the actors there but the freaking
internet went out when I went to the
Head desk that's fine
we understand it's totally fine yeah you
know sad so what is foot wrestling what
is foot worship wrestling look like what
is a match it's like a regular wrestling
match it's just that during the match
after every move you know you put the
foot to the frame so it's host talking
to make it really hot you know what I
mean okay so if you're doing like you
know it's only realistically 15 minute
match you do about eight or nine or
eight or nine minutes just of wrestling
and then it's a hot Central foot worship
at the end for five minutes so you know
if you're doing a headlock throw the guy
on the ground he put the foot to the
face he sniffs in and sucks Toes or if
you do like you know the guy's kicking
you kick to the face or any move then
you put the foot to the face right after
that you know it's his way here to make
it wide wow interesting and I turned the
guy upside down I hang up from the turn
book and I start putting my feet on his
face that's how you weaken the opponent
like in wrestling you know if you watch
wrestling wow wow wow and what are you
guys wearing when you wrestle are you
wearing clothes
well yeah we are I mean I had a hot I
had a hot like uh g-string kind of
bikini kind of thing oh okay
I have a teeny bit of Italian belly but
it's okay it's cute it's lovable you
know so most people wearing like you
could wear a single you'd wear shorts or
anything you want I mean I had two guys
that want to do nude I mean I don't mind
but it's not we're not telling you guys
you have to the whole purpose is feet I
mean yeah you want to see other stuff as
well but you know we just don't want to
always lose the focus because a lot of
guys tell me well I love the feet but I
want to get even more dirtier and I'm
like you can do it if you want to but
our business is the mainly the feet you
know because we just don't want to lose
focus it's not a full-blown porn site
right keep it classy
yeah well I mean the thing is I just
think later on as we progress we could
do a lot more because I have a lot of
guys telling gay and straight that they
want to do a lot more dirty stuff right
you're more than welcome to do it if you
want to start the script you can do that
I'm not going to stop you but there's
guys that just only want to do the feet
and I want to make them comfortable you
know so that's the whole point behind
that but when this guy that carried out
on me you know I was like because he had
really great feet and said he wanted to
do it so I'll make it a star so myself
and Derek were the ones the main ones in
the other guy from New York and we had
some other guy we got but Derek is from
San Antonio and he's really hot he's
Mexican and black he's got hot feet so
okay okay interesting that's nice of a
mix so it was really cool so that's fun
this guy that blew you off he had
beautiful feet you saw this I mean nice
feet I can't see the beautiful nice
feeling you said see man you said you
were going to make him a star that seems
like well
he was young and I think it'd be good to
you know he was so passionate about this
like you're on the phone with me Tom you
really want to do this and be part of
this and then we actually met we flew
down I picked him up from the airport
and then I went to the hotel and then I
went to go Dunkin Donuts and I had to
pick up another actor coming in from a
flight the guy that was from New York is
probably on my flight from New York from
Kennedy but a stupid Uber in Nassau
County didn't make it a broke down so I
bitched him at six o'clock in the
morning at JFK on JetBlue I said you
live in freaking North Bellmore East
Meadow and you can't even get to
freaking JFK Airport really bro I live
in Queens so he got on a later flight
and I had to go back to Tampa to get him
about about five o'clock six o'clock
it's like these guys don't respect what
you're putting together
he just he lost he lost his driver's
license and you were outside or
something and I'm like bro I don't know
how he got on the plane because New York
is not easy to take off on from that but
I was just like this sucks you know at
least he made it though he made his
promise like he told me I I keep my
promise you know some kind of person
paint a picture for me inside you have
like an event Hall uh where you have the
you're in a warehouse It's a warehouse
how is I put an ad on Craigslist a
couple months back and I met this guy
who owns a ring he's also an actor and
he also trains in wrestling he's from
Long Island New York too he lives in
Florida he's a really nice guy who's
willing to to rent to me he said I told
him I like my Venice that's cool so you
know damage that place I don't care what
you do inside which is good it's a very
small place though no air conditioning
it was so hot and sweaty and yeah is
that good the sweatiness or no well at
95 degree Florida weather I guess I
don't know yeah not yeah at a certain
point it turns from not hot to just hot
you know what I mean from well I mean
yeah it's really like in New York it's
only what 62 now and then I mean still
hot inside but okay so I think so you
guys are in this Warehouse so just tell
me kind of what's the situation you guys
have a mat on the floor you guys have a
water no it's an actual wrestling ring
there's a wrestling ring a bunch of
chairs okay wow so what we do with the
audition is they'll sign a waiver
they're in the wrestle in the boom and
beforehand will go over and audition to
see what our roles are going to be and
they're going to activate what moves
they want to do because a lot of them
are not professional wrestlers I don't
expect to be professional wrestles the
whole point of is entertainment it's fun
as long as you like feet that's good so
I explained to them whatever move you
choose like my signature move is pinning
with the toes and the mouth like I'll
jump off the ring and then you know then
I then I get them weak and I put my
tongue in them out and that's how I pin
it or I'll turn them upside down on the
turnbuckle and you know I pretend to do
the Jabs you know like this and that and
then you put the foot on the face and
you're you know standing on their feet
on their face when they're when their
legs are over the turn that sounds a
little dangerous does anyone ever get
hurt
no it's for fun I mean you know what
wrestling is everyone knows what
wrestling is I mean well it sounds like
you're face-stomping people so I don't
know that's good though you know it's
good go by having fun the whole thing's
about to happen but mostly so so what
you're doing is you're filming this for
you're selling my website
so you guys I gotta fix my website
because apparently I didn't realize the
back end with WordPress WordPress has
been really a mess you know these the
developers and stand up so I've been
trying to get the back end six on my own
I don't know too much about technology
is that how you make a living from that
website see man not necessarily like I
told you I have another job I have a job
I work out Long Island I put all my
money from that job into this passion I
just haven't really made too much
because I've been trying to get these
videos going and every time I try to do
shoot you know someone doesn't show up
or I the location I can't rent on time
or something because it's been a
nightmare it's in Florida I'm in New
York so I like to eventually get my own
office in Florida eventually so I have a
place where people can go for additions
and see okay we're here because I don't
want to think it's someone not legit
because I didn't get the space and time
and I organize an event and it turned
out that well gee I fly down there I'm
sorry you didn't give me enough time I
rented to someone else and I had that
the first time I joined it can I ask you
this if you're trying to turn a business
why not just shoot it in New York why go
all the way down to Florida right
because in New York it's been really
hard I've been asking in New York
they're crazy because they want like the
tons of money all those insurance and
the people are just not nice here
what about New Jersey they don't give a
[ __ ] about anything there I don't know
maybe New Jersey but I looked around it
just to direct the ring somewhere they
want to know if you are established in
this big big school or this and this
they don't just raise people in general
and do you try not to tell people what
it's for if you can avoid it well I
tried to not to because obviously
instead of anybody's business I mean
we're doing wrestling shoes I tell
people it's a wrestling video people
understand that you know because people
do come how do people do it as well I
just try not to bring it up because you
just can't tell if people are are
ignorant or narrow-minded you know we
don't need death threats or anybody
attacking us if I did make the call one
time to somebody in the Bronx a couple
of this is about two years ago and the
guy like literally gave me death threats
I'm like bro I I don't know I'm just
asking
and that's why you know like I said I'm
a nice person I know my city at the back
of my hand all five boroughs but you
know it's risky even going to the Bronx
he said it's a bit he's got to bring
somewhere of rent and he's like what is
it for I said for an alternative
wrestling I said we're doing videos oh
he goes like this this and this and it's
just very nasty and also next to another
guy's texting me with death threats I
said dude I just want to rent your ring
I don't you don't have to be involved
you have to be there I just want to rent
your freaking ring you know we had an
Express very similar experience renting
a ring were they homophobic no no it
wasn't about homophobia but remember he
got very upset with us when we rented
this dude I don't know what's Rob
there's people that rent rings they're
just [ __ ] yeah lunatics man I don't
know what it is and I told the guy in
the Bronx you know I'm like dude I'm
just having fun I'm from New York he's
like well I cannot people I don't know I
said dude it's a video shoot I said
first of all you don't know who I am I
could be some high-end Hollywood person
and you'll screw me over dude yeah
and the guy was like an idiot and he
says threaten me I said keep the threat
up I mean I'm gonna call the police and
they stopped and eventually and I put an
ad out in New York and kept going people
in New York are just very ignorant and
narrow-minded people they're not
accepting they they don't not an
open-minded City bro I'm wondering I
came back from Australia and I'm like
this is not the city I grew up in people
here are just everything they're
oppressed about everything they're
[ __ ] sexually oppressed about this
it's a joke dude it's like no funny it's
not fun no more New York is like living
in Saudi Arabia why don't you and and
Florida is more open-minded well I find
Florida it's ironic that Florida is a
lot more open and understanding because
people I guess are from New York and all
over the place I think just the warm
weather people are just more chill down
there on many things and most people
don't give a rat's ass about [ __ ] in
Florida what I found out which I like
because people just not in people's
business but here it's just like you try
to do something and they want to know
everything what's going on it's like you
want to know my freaking you know what
what else you want to know you know so
that's why I did it in Florida this guy
was really cool so I'm gonna rent for me
more often okay so I told them so that's
why I was trying to plan these events
every so often in Florida that's why
when I figured I was down there I could
could have done a great video on the
hotel but the hotel internet was so
cheap days in you know you can't expect
to be the best quality so bring me back
into the uh the warehouse so let me ask
you this um are do men are you guys
finishing yourselves in there or is it
just the feet like is there is there do
you jerk off in there is there dicks in
hands or no
Mr Wrestling I mean yeah
I'm hard on
gar
you know it's just it's logical it's a
sexual event I have a question do you
ever stomp on on their penises
I mean some wrestlers do that I I've
done it a few times on their heads I
could I've done it a few times I'm
trying to stomp on their heads but I
could tell they want me to stop on their
penises because they when they when they
do the script they're like you gotta
Kick here kick there because I try to do
the wrestling to be you know not to look
so bad I mean I know some moves I look
really bad as I'm not a great wrestler
myself but when I jump off the ring I
looked like I fell so I had to redo it
again that's pretty bad I mean because
I'm not not used to jumping off high
Rings you know here I'm in my 40s I'm
not like I'm 20 where I'm so my legs are
so you know everything I do the best I
can but you know when I when I do try to
do the moves I do some moves I like more
than anything else but we try to try to
make it look good to make it fun not
look so bad
so how many people were in the warehouse
with you it was four it was just three
four guys okay yeah and you guys are
just having a good do you guys ever do
like a free-for-all situation all four
of you in the ring well I was trying to
do that I we did a tag team which was
great and then we do like moment
wrestling and socks and this they have
to socks off with the teeth the slaves
oh wow the next year we're going to get
short to say slaves and be a good slave
that'd be kind of cool because we're
going to do slave training next which is
really hard to spice it up but yeah I'm
curious um
for most people when they have a sexual
encounter
they'll come to an orgasm right and then
that that marks kind of the end of
rather stuff people could keep orgasms
you can do more than one but I'm just
wondering during the foot War shipping
is there orgasms happening how is this
something I didn't look in their pants
when they were
oh I'm getting my feet worse worship
them enjoying it you don't even so so
let me find himself let me ask you this
is the dick less appealing to you than
the foot
I'm not saying that it's just it's not
it's not the right video
I mean I could do full-bone porn if I
wanted to but I just threw the feet okay
interesting I mean I've done other stuff
too but I'm just trying to understand
I'm just trying to understand the uh
the culture you know what I mean I'm
just trying to understand the culture
well the whole point is you love feet
you're turned on so it doesn't let your
cop's gonna get no matter what and can I
ask you this have you ever orgasm from
someone worshiping your feet when you
didn't touch yourself
a few times myself first that's exciting
I remember it happened to me once as a
long story because I this is a start
every time I was in Vietnam on 2015
because I was living in Australia for
seven years so I was traveling to
Vietnam and I went to this you know
Vietnam's a very oppressed country but I
found this this mature place off big
path that had no name on it because they
keep it hidden and I went there and this
guy was just magically sucking on my
toes what question myself yeah like he
was massaging me and I kept rubbing my
feet and just got to my feet normally I
have to push somebody to my feet I mean
it's Vietnam I mean they're the
masseuses and you go to these these
these doors that like these these hidden
buildings that are not known because
obviously Vietnam's an oppressed country
Here I Am the crazy American heart you
know going just getting so all these
sexual okay hold on I gotta I'm
captivated by the story so you're in
Vietnam
so how did you find this building you're
I imagine you're like wandering Through
the Jungle or some [ __ ] I was walking
around and I wanted to get a massage
because people said massage are cheap in
Vietnam okay and you're not thinking
about feet you're just looking for a
back massage I just want a full body
massage
I did that okay so I'm laying on this
this floor and these three guys and also
I'm laying there and I'm just gonna I'm
getting rubbed and I'm sitting there
going like this and I'm like so high as
a standing up okay hold on hold on
wait hold on
hold on hold on
so you're sitting there getting massaged
by three guys three guys
yeah three guys and you're fully erect
at this time I could not but it just
felt good and then all of a sudden I'm
kicking because these I was the guys
were like massaging me and all of a
sudden my leg and the guy just jumps on
my feet and licks them and I was really
blown away and I actually blew a low
without touching myself oh my God
all right hold on you're you're covering
too much ground I I need all the little
details too man it was wild like in the
third okay so hold up so you're sitting
you're laying on your back
these three dudes are massaging you
you're fully course I don't think they
expected
[Laughter]
you're fully torqued under the towel
there's no towel bro
[Laughter]
hold on hold on wait wait wait wait wait
[ __ ] [ __ ] is real okay see man hold the
phone wait you laid down and got a
massage from three dudes on me okay on
me but when I was laying on my stomach
when I turned over I said screw the
towel because it was a really warm off
building it was a bit steamy inside
because next to it was a was a uh a bad
thing so we were outside next to that so
the inside was really hot so why we're a
towel so I'm laying on this little
makeshift like what they call it little
thing you lay on and when they're
massaging me one's doing the legs one's
doing the shoulders one's doing you know
around the middle and I and I'm so erect
but they don't touch it until later
right this is a funny story and I I
twitched a bit because it got me tickled
because he went between my legs and my
pritched my foot I was down there
rubbing my foot he just puts his face
and starts licking my toes and it's
amazing which I have to tell guys to
lick my toes he just went there on a
whim and I was like well all of a sudden
I blew a load and it went over then he
starts jerking me and three guys start
jerking oh my God bro yeah it's in my
life
oh dude are you sure this wasn't like a
gay masseuse place like uh this was just
like every Vietnamese or I'm an American
guy just run around Vietnam by myself
people want us to lose this crazy white
guy and I'm looking it was like two
o'clock this is incredible
way so you're on your back the dude
touches your feet or he he all of a
sudden licks your feet and then you blow
your load and then what was that what
was their reaction when you just all of
a sudden like came I don't know I just
kicked it I said Gee I'm so sorry I
don't think you understand you're
apologetic
I don't think he understood English I
said I'm so sorry he started smiling
goes no no the problem I'm like no I'm
so sorry I didn't mean to blow it on you
I just you know you blew it on him you
see man sexual well partly on him and
partly on the wall it was there was a
lot of money you know did you did you
point it towards him semen or was it
just what well they were leaning over
and the guy that was on my leg I guess
the back of his head was there and it
went and just went oh on his head too
man
I don't know what happened it was wild
but it was cool it was fun yeah okay
wait wait wait wait wait wait hold on
the world
and I had so much fun you know this was
a hidden building and then I had to get
a chance to die take me back on a
motorcycle taxi and he must have knew
what was going on because he was
bringing all the westerners there so
maybe they knew there was some secret
thing because he couldn't speak English
so I just said massage he goes He points
in that building there's no sign
language oh [ __ ] that's how you found it
it's just a building that's just no name
with a light on it and you go she goes
and I woke up and that's the thing you
sign a book and then you have you have
to ring a door ring a bell and someone
comes down the tower to get you and then
you just lay down and get a massage you
know what you know what's interesting
see man a lot of people have Vietnam
flashbacks but not quite like this
yeah
well you know it's quite wild I mean you
know being in the third world country I
don't think people without even
oppressed at all I mean they were just
having fun people seem to be wild and
crazy they don't give a [ __ ] about stuff
yeah so you went over there oh my God
after that I flew down from North this
was North Vietnam Saigon was about the
bigger city I went to another masseuse
place there but they spoke more English
and the guy asked me do you want to play
with your you know part I said well if
you want to I'm not going to make you
but that time I was just a regular but I
think it's an extra charge you know for
for the well they try to pull out of
Michael don't pull a massage and massage
you didn't care you're like yo I'm not
paying for a tug I'm not paying for it
no okay I'm not good so Saigon was more
greedy than Northern because Saigon was
more Western so they want to get more
money out of the northern Vietnam they
were more happy I mean they're just
they're just offering you an extra
service though that that seems fine
right I did mine
it was interesting though but that was
like one of my hold on let me go back to
the shack so you come on this guy and
then he they immediately go down to the
feet and the dick is that what's
happening
all three of them are working the shaft
I can't no I came when he touched my
feet and I I kind of twitched a bit and
then afterwards so it was a bit awkward
they stopped and then he was doing more
of the body he went close to him I think
he wanted to touch my penis but was
afraid to and then he starts grabbing it
and it still had come on I thought the
[ __ ] had been dried up I had no towels
dry at all and he's playing with it and
he's trying to jerk me I'm like no don't
jerk they already came because after
it's sensitive it gets ticklish when you
start jerking yeah
not to jerking up after I came yeah he's
he's too late yeah I wasn't right though
I mean
so ultimately
um
how much did you end up paying them do
you remember
and it was 10 US Dollars ten bucks damn
for all that
it's showing the Vietnam two dollars is
like a lot of money for them they make
two dollars in Vietnam that's like a
salary for them I you know I need
America to be Filthy Rich there I mean
God it's like can I ask you a question
though do you think they're like sex
trafficked or these were willing uh
participants I think they were willing
people I don't know I mean
says we're just Taurus what the [ __ ] do
we know you know you know I don't speak
English I'm just going to Vietnam
vacation and literally you know they
just like the Americans in the
westerners I like the Australians new
zealanders Canadians and they see the
white person oh boy maybe we can so you
can get money you think they were
they're gay men who enjoyed it or maybe
they'll just service anyone who's there
for the for the 10 bucks I don't know I
didn't ask then speak English I just
kept smiling at me and I'm just smiling
I imagine they liked it they didn't like
it you wouldn't be smiling I mean really
you know but it was some wild stuff and
I really had a good time it's like wow
wow we're trying to have fun everywhere
I go and then you're gone
I haven't gone back since no no I
haven't but I got back to Australia I
might I'm not going to go back to
Australia that's a hell of a story there
buddy you just came on a masseuse I had
fun too in Fiji my life after Vietnam
went to feed him after that and I had
fun with having you know same thing
happened in the guy's truck in Fiji
outside the beach Wait wait okay so the
same thing happened it's making me in
Fiji okay the same thing happened what
do you mean by this
well I was in the South Pacific I want I
love to travel travel is fun so I flew
into food when everyone's rubbing your
feet down of course you know no I was in
this hotel you know it was a hostel we
had a good time hey have you seen uh hey
c-man have you seen Full Metal Jacket
yes I saw that long time yeah no that's
an old jacket Full Metal Jacket yes
thank you
yeah so everywhere you go people are
just trying to grab kiss your feet and
grab your dick no I don't think it was
that I just think it was just a moment
probably you know okay great
um you know all right fantastic wow
incredible
so let me ask you um
so we've we prepared some content for
you that we want you to uh rate for us
okay now we know you're a fan of feet
and I know you have a specific type of
photo you like
generally you like the feet on the
pedals of the car oh oh oh something
came up yeah hold on hold on one second
this is the guy from guy from Ireland
now oh yeah can we yeah just you can
answer just let us hear masseuse from
Nam hey what's up yeah this is good
you're home okay
it went well looked pretty good no I
just had um I just had like iced tea to
visit for lunch that was about it I feel
like drinking ice tea that's about it
not much
but okay how are things with you in Long
Island okay
how is this real
yeah
I'm [ __ ] dying
okay
what happened
I'm talking to you I'm talking to you
what's going on what's Happening
well can you give me can I call you back
in 20 minutes is that okay
all right cool I'll do that all the best
take it easy cheers sorry to uh sorry to
interrupt your call like that I don't
normally get a phone call in a minute I
was my friend sorry yeah I'm sorry I'm
sorry that you had to cut that off for
us no he wants to hang out I'm gonna go
to Farmingdale there's a spot we hang
out and chill in Farmingdale off the I
I-95 which is the LIE near Exit 49 are
you trying to get people to meet you
there
just hang out you know people find you
there at what time
I don't know Long Island just really
sucks but you know I just want to hang
out with some of them all anyway all
right so so anyway I was saying you have
a specific taste you like the feet on
the pedals nude right a little tan if I
recall pretty much anywhere like I said
foot footage like feet anywhere okay
well my my business is just the driving
and wrestling but you know feet is
anywhere we try to use technology to to
uh get something that you're interested
in we asked um Dolly too which is an
advanced AI that creates photos based on
written prompts so tell me how did Dolly
2 do and uh representing nice feet for
you here is uh what do you think about
this one this is kind of a Sandy foot on
what looks like a gym mat
can you see that see man
hold on let me just try to see that yeah
go ahead
um I don't know my my thing where where
is it oh it's weird okay can you see it
oh I see yeah oh yeah it could be cool
that could be pretty nice I mean it's
it's it doesn't it looks like it's just
a computer image it's not like it's a
live person
so I guess that still looks good though
it just looks good you know so you're
not a fan of hentai I'm assuming well I
mean I just I guess I like real wow look
at this one that looks cool getting that
looks cool yeah it looks good I mean
both of them are good pretty impressive
right a freaking computer made this is
there oh now look at this one that's
pretty interesting that's pretty
impressive that's a good one right
yes it's pretty impressive it's good yes
it's really good I don't know
um I would say that's a pretty good um I
think that's a pretty good one I would
say maybe a seven eight on that one wow
what I looked at it is I prefer human to
produce stuff I mean AI is just like a
robot producing stuff I'm the kind of
person it's great videos but I like more
of when a human could produce because
it's more natural than real we're just
we're just we're testing the limits of
Technology but seven or eight here's
another one wow what do you think about
this one
down Canal looks good actually that
looks really good wow yeah take a look
Feast your eyes what do you rate this
one
those ones look real huh see man they
look kind of real but I mean again since
I knew that it was an AI doing it if you
had told me there was just a person
doing it hey you're not touching
yourself are you see man no I'm not
touching myself let me see your hands
all right
I'm just holding the laptop all right
right
um uh okay wow look at this that's a
real that that that's incredible isn't
it
oh yeah yeah one two three four toes
well you're very you got very quiet what
happened oh yeah there's four toes
right it's missing a toe it's not a
problem I didn't catch that
cement got really quiet dude
no I'm I'm I'm I'm it's pretty good it
looks pretty nice
let's see man that's cool now imagine
trying to drive with your feet you know
the funny thing is I did see a video
years back guy had no arms and it's kind
of cool but he was driving with his feet
and I actually sent the message to him I
said the great idea I mean you know
I mean it was kind of cruel because the
guy was like you know he had no light no
arms he's driving a car so it's like so
did you make contact with this guy with
no arms no I saw the video was like a
disabled video somebody did I said I
said told him it's a positive that's
great that's a great thing is to keep up
the good work I mean you have to yeah
it's impressive stable doesn't mean your
life is over you know sure yeah of
course especially if you're using your
feet more I mean that's a that's just a
plus so I'm assuming if you were to meet
a guy with no arms that obviously
wouldn't uh wouldn't be a problem if his
name is Matt you never know his name
could be mad oh making a little joke
about the Norms no legs yeah gotcha uh
oh my God you're gonna love these ones
these are all AI generated see man what
did you type to get these you guys I
didn't yeah what are you say yeah
what was it Ian Ian you uh created these
did you not or was it a camera yeah I
think it was like 4K realistic
photo of
man's foot pushing the pedal on a car
you gotta be right that down like the
more specific you are the the more
accurate and is this one pretty good for
you see man you're getting really quiet
you're not you're not jerking off right
no I'm looking at the back yeah right
he's analyzing he's analyzing yeah so
how do you rate this one I never seen
you I've never seen you be so quiet see
man you're usually because I'm very
talkative yeah okay
um that looks pretty good I like the
size of those feet I like the toes I
like the bones so yeah it's a nice
structure it's really nice there's more
this one's pretty wild what do you think
of this one
let's see let's go and see
it's very interesting shaped foot there
long yeah that's pretty good that's
interesting
it's pretty long yeah it's really long
for wow long toes you like those long
toes right I've never seen feet like
that I've had any small but they pretty
must be nice to play with yes wow
and okay interesting so this okay now
this one's pretty wild what the [ __ ] is
this
he's got a wide foot wait how did you
how did you get this one
I mean I don't know I've never really
had many wide feets like that I mean
some people do like it some don't I mean
there's different likes in the foot
community so you really can't say
anything some people like right
what about that amount of hair is that
something you like or dislike
no because I never really questioned it
I looked at the freedom I've never
really
no you can answer it go ahead it's okay
yeah we'll wait see man well fine
no it must be one of those dead um I
don't know I don't know
somebody from Missouri called me I don't
know anybody in Missouri yes uh probably
telemarketer yes sir um so here okay so
so that was interesting actually the the
computer did a really good job it sounds
like yeah yeah yeah yeah now
um
I made a special thing for you uh c-man
I made a video for you because I know
last time you hated my feet let's just
not mince words you gave me like a three
out of ten and it's okay
listen I'm not offended it's okay
okay but I've made you a special video
that's like you're exact likes and I
want to get your take on this I filmed
this in my car
okay and I just want to get uh your take
if I did this good or not all right I'm
gonna play for you
all right those are your feet okay those
are my feet
go ahead
no it's good that's good right that's
good okay it's a lot better looks nice
the sun on it maybe you got stuck you
like the artistic well it's nice you
probably got Sun you know California's
son everywhere why not yeah
the white that Elmer's Glue looks worse
so could you rate this on 10 because
last one was a three which is fine and
and be honest I would give that a six
now
wow
but no one but nobody's really got
really hot feet like me like I have the
hottest view can you put your feet on
the screen confidence
well I've always do can we see the money
makers there uh see man well I gotta
take my suctions okay sure yeah give us
a free show a little tease let's see
what a ten let's do it so you think your
feet are a ten c-man right well nine or
ten oh my God whoa It's a good it's a
good it's pretty good it's pretty good
that's all right I guess yeah
I mean I've seen some you know they're
pretty hot in New York yes so you would
you give your feet a 10
I would say probably a nine I mean it's
really hard to stay perfect feet because
No One's Gonna have really perfect
anything out there all right well have
you ever seen a 10.
I don't know I mean you know if someone
got hot feet you turned on and you want
the moments right but I mean everyone's
got a different take of what's hot
what's not you know two years like short
stubby scene and you know some people
might not so I mean you turned out by
Phoenix when you see from a video but
sometimes you go close up and say well
I'm turned on but then you see I don't
know but you know my my thing is I think
my feet about me there you go well it's
a good thing to believe in yourself
that's important
we do the chat is saying they're 10 out
of 10 so
thank you everybody yeah yeah they're
into it of course I well so so this is
exciting so do you want to tell people
again you're going to be on the turnpike
at the truck stop on uh
I'm just kidding stop don't tell your
address yeah I'm not saying anything but
I'm saying there's a parking lot off the
airline
and you know you go there hang out and
just people
it's just a place where it got it's a
place where guys go to meet other guys
kind of situation well I don't know it's
normally a stop for like buses and stuff
those across from a big company building
in Farmingdale but I like going by
watching the planes I like planes and
planes land Republic airports around 110
near Amityville which is nice so I like
that are you a pilot c-man did we learn
that at some point flying lessons
because 20 something years ago I wanted
to be a commercial pilot 30 years 45
years so I've taken lessons but you know
I really couldn't afford it you know I'm
not rich so growing up flight school had
took lessons two or three times a week
Republic Airport and also in Florida and
something a plane is so free it's so
Russian it's amazing rush just getting
up there in a two-seater Cessna it's
awesome you know
um so I like watching planes I like
being in the cockpit you know cockpit do
you fly uh shoeless or are you barefoot
well usually they wanted to fly would
probably wear flip-flops just hot but
normally when winter I wear shoes they
tell you it's a big deal book because
you know in the plane but I had no
problem because you know hit the rudder
pedals is nothing hey man what do you
think of this I'm just curious uh is
this something that you sat down with or
no that would be wild
horses got like I'm made that was that
wasn't a robot
that could be tons of you know that'll
be you could be into that you could be
into that a lot of toes that's a lot of
toes
just imagine that on your face see man
with all the toes wiggling around
there's that silence no because I'm
reading the chat I'm reading the chat
[Music]
um but anyway like I said it was pretty
cool that was cool so I guess I do like
to watch planes land it's really fun to
watch different planes at night
all right so so there's one more thing
uh uh there's one more thing I want to
show you and then we'll say goodbye I
know you're a busy man
I'm not that busy I'm all today so I
have plenty of time I know the fans love
me out oh I would be a great asset for
your shows but you already are you are
all right
discussion what do you think about this
wow
let me see hold on
that's pretty cool that's pretty cool
yeah that's wild [ __ ] yeah yeah find the
rudder no I don't wanna now see man hold
on I don't wanna I don't want to break
it to you but this is a woman
oh no no yeah but it's I know it doesn't
matter it's just really cool to just fly
Barefoot exactly okay because I thought
you were I mean that's really cool to
like I said it's really cool to be in a
plane or helicopter you know so all
right see man listen uh what a treat
what I was gonna say is that if anybody
wants to wrestle me I need any guys out
there want to wrestle me and Derek in
the sunbus in our next wrestling shoot
we'd love to have that you know I'd like
to see if anybody out there would be man
enough to arrest us man enough
loser worship when his feet be kind of
cool be awesome you know
um it'd be nice it'd be nice to have
that for my my next shoot you know there
is more people and great there's
probably an age a specific age you want
people to be at least yes 21 to
55.21
but unless you're really not gonna play
games and say You're Gonna Come
someone's more mature than you know
they're gonna really want I appreciate
that it's 21 plus but what's wrong with
it you don't like old people feet I
don't mind but how many six-year-olds
gonna arrest you in a thing I mean some
of them could be in good shape I mean I
don't mind I've seen some all the people
that want to wrestle I'm open to it but
you know you don't get many 65 year old
people tell me I want to wrestle and
then you know it's nice if they do I'm
not against it I mean it's fun enjoy
what you love but I'm just thinking you
know why not you know so um but I'll say
if anybody wants the rest of me I'm
gonna plan a shoot in a couple of months
back in St Petersburg Florida the temp
Bay Area
um I'd like to have a nice spread at
least seven or eight guys you can have
really fun with this there it is to make
it amazing and I'm also planning another
uh foot fetish video uh shoot either in
New York or Florida but I'm just trying
to plan something there it's going to be
really erotic to be good we already
found Ninja's feet yeah that's kind of
cool
Seaman ladies and gentlemen the world is
your oyster there's so much to look
forward to so much I'd love to be on
your show I'd love to come out one day
and be on your show like you are on the
show now
in person okay and you're in L.A let us
know we can figure out some fun segment
yeah that'd be cool oh you know we're
happy should I pitch that I mean we're
having a live show maybe we could have
some kind of segment with you there
during the live show could be
interesting but uh what do you mean why
isn't this live now no but I'll get like
a live audience yeah like a venue like
750 people live oh that could be cool
but let's go but I'll tell you one thing
I would love to I would love to worship
Leonardo DiCaprio speak I really would
and I'd love to worship Shawn Mendes you
know he's a pretty oh yeah he was number
one on yeah right yeah all right I would
love to worship Leonardo DiCaprio's feet
oh my God so I'll work on that for you
okay I'll get in touch I'll I'll reach
out to them Sean I actually know Shawn
Mendes I think that's there's a chance
to make that happen wow I don't know I
just one of these videos I remember in
like is I just I don't know what it was
it was pretty cool I'm sure there's a
lot of other people have really good
feet out there too so I wonder how
Hollywood people actually watch this
show a lot of them actually do or no
Hollywood in Hollywood Hollywood people
oh yeah no I'm in I'm in tight with a
lot of uh yeah we got we got some
connections I don't want to oversell it
I'll I'll leverage
I know Leonardo DiCaprio I'll try to
meet you I'll see if we can get him to
lend you his feet for uh how long do you
need well how long would you need with
him just so I know what to pitch of him
I don't know it's how long he wants to
feel good oh [ __ ] well I want to ask his
agent like yo we need him for like 10
minutes so like the less the better so
what do you need really to get satisfied
foreign
I guess I could say probably an hour and
a half two hours wow that's a long
session that's expensive for two hours
young gravy I didn't make that happen
I'm not gonna be able to get you Leo for
two hours I can get you for 30 minutes
30 minutes is fine a quickie okay okay
so so I'm gonna leverage are you
interested in Brad Pitt I have a
connection there too
I don't know I mean he's not too bad I
guess I don't know what his feet look
like I know I've seen little carton yeah
maybe not maybe Brad Pitt his feet okay
I'm gonna work on that okay and we'll
see see what you can maybe set up for
you because I know they're only going to
give us a 30 minute slot maybe I can get
him one after the other so we can start
with Leo
and then when he's got to go eventually
after 30 minutes we can Sean Mendes will
be waiting and ready for you after so
it'll be like a hour-long session back
to back does that sound okay
if he wants Oliver tree we could do that
for like 24 hours I got I have to I
don't know what is what is this feedback
they're disgusting they're pretty they
might be pretty hard I think a lot of
guys have sure it's like a one star it's
disgusting they're small and his stuff
it could be good hey sometimes you can
flick the whole foot in your mouth at
that smoke oh okay can I ask you a
question since you mentioned that yes
um
without making any assumptions so
forgive me I'm just only asking because
I've been always fascinated
with this thing called Fish Fest have
you heard of that no I never heard of
that so there's a community of men and
like you are into footstuff they're into
a thing called fisting which is oh yes I
see what says yeah so I was wondering if
I don't have anybody stick something
well what I was wondering see man is if
there's a Venn diagram of the fisting
people and defeat people if if we're
ever going to be able to get a whole
foot in someone's ass well someone tried
that once in one of the foot parties a
long time ago um not mine but one of my
friends and he almost went up there but
he said it was painful but I don't think
it could because if you look at the
sides with foot it's not like it's very
hard to get into a hole like that a sort
of thinking yeah so it was a pain I
don't know but I'm the kind of person I
don't want anything really in my butt
yeah you're not into the uh you're not
on the fisting side you're on the I mean
I had somebody who wanted to put fruit
between my toes like I said the last
show I'm not into the fruit between the
toes and that's not into Fruit I don't
know what it is you know I mean I don't
know if they want to do it between my
toes but I will never suck fruit of
someone's toes I just think it's it's
not natural it's just odds
who did it hurt for the butt hole guy or
the foot guy
my friend taught me to hurt but he told
him to stop it because he said was he
receiving or was he or was he putting
the foot in he did both but at first he
wasn't he said putting it wasn't as bad
but this was like years ago and they
told me that was difficult because it's
hard to maneuver and it was like when
you're when you're turned on for the
moment you don't have time to waste you
just give up because if someone wants to
feel good you're not gonna wait 40
minutes to put something into somebody
they're like okay I'm done I'm leaving
goodbye kind of thing you know yeah so
that's why you have to have my friend
explained to me fisting I'm not into
fisting I'll never be interface yeah but
he's explaining to me that it's an art
and you really have to be careful and I
don't want I just want to clarify I'm
not saying that like
all gay men are a monolith who are into
either one I'm just saying there's
different communities and I was just
wondering there's different fetishes out
there absolutely but you know not every
fetish is the same no and the other one
is different but the thing is you know a
lot of people always ask me like the
same thing with to put a foot in the in
something ass I mean I would do to
somebody I just don't think it would
feel right and I don't think I would I
could even do it you know let me ask you
guys so one last question see man I'm
just kidding do you would you engage in
regular kind of traditional sex acts or
does it have to be involved feet to get
you excited well I think like me like
every other foot guy too of course you
want foot including every sex act
because I know no foot guy I know on a
plant whatever goes without the the
vanilla sex doesn't excite you you need
more well does but like a lot of foot
guys who say the same thing you want to
you want to go to the feet because you
like feet that's the first thing you're
going to go to next time you're having
sex with someone you're looking at his
feet you're so turned on you're gonna go
further I mean I've never heard of foot
guys never touching the feet yet I mean
if their cowards afraid to touch the
feet
I find it interesting you call them
cowards why why because people don't go
for what they want and they're like well
I should have done the feet from the
sexy that's your fault you're done with
the sex see you later currently I had
friends like that with me like they
wanted to play with my feet but they're
afraid to and I said what were you
waiting for like you just ruined the
moment you know what I mean like if you
like this stuff don't go for other
things first go for that that's what I'm
expecting you know foot guys want that
all foot guys there it is He-Man has
said it all you know he's done it all
well and there's so much left to see and
do uh just so excited for you
yeah and thank you em for the gifted
and so see man well I'm gonna wish you I
have a fantastic weekend
of getting all kinds of interesting and
strange fun feet action
and uh I will and I look forward to
speaking to you again and if you're in
La let us know okay
I definitely want all the best and stay
well hopefully that can actually be
Leonardo DiCaprio or showing me no I'm
gonna be working on that I'll let you
know no promises I'm gonna talk to the
agents we don't want to overpower
do you want to film this or can it just
be like a private thing I don't mind I
want a private I just really want to see
that because I don't think Leo's going
to want to be on your website and just
no you won't be on my website
I don't care I could be the darkest
slave too I like that you'll be the
dirtiest slave to Leah yes and also
you're right okay okay okay great I'm
gonna work on that and we'll let you
know okay
all right cool cool chair would you be
willing to pay I know he he he usually
asks for compensation for his time
like 30 minutes that's not not a [ __ ]
prostitute no you oh no you pay all
Ethan no you pay him donation to his
charity well for his time
okay
listen I'm trying to make the I'm moving
mountains for you if his age
donation maybe I'll give him a little
bit of donation from here okay okay I'm
just saying
this baby you're asking me to move
mountains for you see man I'm just
saying keep their stocks too don't be
kind of nice I don't know what's cool
but all right we'll have fun we'll
figure it out all right all right
thank you buddy we'll talk soon okay you
you have a good time thanks man thank
you
that is c-man ladies and gentlemen
from Long Island wow that was worth the
wait that was definitely worth the wait
we learned a lot
we learned a whole lot about c-man and
about the hot in Vietnam yeah learned a
lot about Vietnam that's like a really
super weird version of deer hunter
it's like the alternate ending the
director's got you know every time I
hear CCR now I'm gonna think of his
story right yeah why Fortunate Son
Fortunate Son he was a Fortunate Son in
that thing dude
creating c-man Revival
well listen those that know c-man know
that this man is uh he loved he's It's
All About Love of the Game with this guy
and he's one of a kind it's pretty cool
I guess so do you think we'll be able to
get Leo and Shawn Mendes
I'm working on it it's a long shot
that's why I kept trying to downplay it
because I don't I don't want him to get
like really hyped about it and Olivia
you reach out yeah yeah yeah and we'll
see we'll see what about Bobby Lee
people said in the chat that's that's
more feasible I'm sure he'd be dead it'd
be so cool if like whatever guests are
at the live show they just come out and
see man is like you eight you four
straighten people I mean on my feet I'd
be down to bring Bobby and uh Oliver and
uh post Malone maybe because you gotta
just bring him a buffet yeah yeah
but you know it could be cool if we have
a
curtain and we all put our phone and he
has to say which is his favorite foot or
slash goose foot is blind blind test
double blind test
interesting but I'm also feeling pretty
confident I'm feeling pretty happy not
only I lost weight but uh I got a six
from c-man it did pretty good yeah if I
recall I think the highest grade he gave
last time was Zach's brother got a six
so I'm feeling like a million bucks
he's a tough crater oh people are saying
Hassan yeah he would love his songs for
you
I'm sure he would go crazy for those
Howie Mandel sure I'm sure he'd be down
for that
wow one of my friends c-man bent over I
guess [ __ ] we gotta go move on to our
main segment oh yeah there's still a
main segment there's the yeah tier list
okay yeah all right so let's get let's
just jump into that
um
I feel like that was the main segment I
know it kind of became but didn't it it
was a whole Feast it was Thanksgiving
dinner man I actually got to pee again
so I'm gonna I'm gonna go do that and
then am I gonna I'm gonna open the album
and we'll do it so yeah I have the tier
list over here so I can kind of operate
that but okay you should show the album
because they're much bigger you know
versions okay I'm gonna go to the
bathroom I'll be right back and we'll
get to the click bait Olympics
sounds good so I can give some setup for
this actually uh we're talking about
what we're going to talk about today
yesterday and uh we're mentioning how
Phil DeFranco has been stepping up his
click bait game and uh he made him yeah
he may be coming for Ethan's title and
so then we happened to just you know
browse through some of our past videos
and we uh you know you forget some of
the titles and thumbnails we've used in
the past so we thought it'd be a fun
segment to to we kind of remembered that
about a year ago we went through a
period of like
I don't know it's probably like two
months three months where we just
decided to amuse ourselves by doing the
most over-the-top click bait that we
could think of
um with zero shame yeah which uh today
was kind of an echo of that that's sort
of why we did it yeah at one of these
style of uh click baits for today's
episode which by the way this this thumb
I'm looking at the thumbnail for today's
episode right now it is an Alzheimer
yeah it really is and last night when we
were throwing out ideas for like the big
the last click bait The Click bait of
all click baits whenever anybody gave
anything it was like nope we did that
yeah nope yeah yeah
we've been there done that but yeah I
mean Philly really is leaning into the
clickbait but I gotta say he's behind
the wave a little bit because
he's been I mean he's like click baiting
like Belle Delphine we were on that wave
like two three years ago that's true
that's right needs to catch up a little
bit yeah give it the time and he he also
like always talks about the stories like
like come on you just gotta say sentence
dude and you're good
somebody's saying a hospital click bait
is asked here well yeah you clicky you
may be right about that and that is
definitely one that made it into the
album uh do we include the uh thinking
process uh that led to the hospital one
I think they're talking about a
different hospital one essentially but
yeah we did I did okay yeah we have one
in there that we showed once on the show
but we never ended up using right and we
showed Cam's process of going through
that yes yeah that is in the album and
so that one we should probably just do
I don't even know if it's fair to rate
that one because it was never actually
yeah it's more of a goof and a gap it's
at the very end it's at the end so we'll
we'll get to that do it how the sausage
is made yeah oh yeah yeah there's a lot
of love and craft and care that goes
into these thumbnails let me tell you
usually you know 10 minutes before we go
live
the Franco's click bait game what's he
doing that's so crazy it's not so crazy
okay so like just look at yesterday's
episode it's a great example and we can
kind of explain like what led us to
wanting to do this so if you just go
over to sexy Phil's Channel
yep and you need to know Bell Delphine
yep daddy so Bel Delphine versus Anna De
armas so it's like okay versus right so
like did they get into some sort of
drama against each other are they
beefing on Twitter what's going on okay
and then you click on it and you go
through it and it's just a story about
on a basically saying that like I guess
she's done a number of sex scenes in
movies and those sex scenes wind up on
porn websites and she's upset about that
because this upset Bell or Anna Anna sex
okay and then Phil just makes the point
you know it's not like somebody like
Bill Delphine who does this on purpose
that's it that's the verses wow oh wow
you're like you know what's funny I saw
this on my homepage I was like that's a
bit of a stretch that's a bit of a
stretch versus well yeah and just
managing to get Bell Delphine in the
thumbnails pretty impressive right when
I saw that I was like hmm I don't think
anything came up there because whenever
she goes on the internet everyone talks
about it yeah but there it is well
played Phil he got he got like more
views than the last one
the the disturbing truth about beyond
meat uh whatever
these scammers are getting worse
we need to talk about True Crime content
wow horrible coward Brett Favre exposed
and he doesn't do it all the time it was
just that one's good that one's good
well he we know that we know that he's
good at that he'll mention me and
passing right I'm the biggest passing
way just so he could drop me in the
thumbnail and trust me I love that
that's that's a compliment I mean the
fact that
that he thinks that helps his viewership
is is just a huge dub am I right
absolutely I mean wow
but yeah that just got the conversation
starting uh started and you're like you
know he needs to really step up his game
though if he wants to get on our level
and then I believe I went and
screenshotted one of you know the one
and you you in the hospital or some [ __ ]
it's so funny
yeah we got pretty good some of these
are just incredible so um this episode
will be erased in 24 hours this one is
not that impressive
what was the click bait again
or what what were we referring to in the
episode it was a zoom episode like we
zoomed in you had covid and then it
wasn't a good episode so you're like
we're gonna delete this yeah right I
think that it really it came up at the
end of the episode you were like this is
the worst episode ever we should change
the title to this episode we'll be
deleted
that's really good and I love that it's
just a small comment at the end of a
three hour podcast right but it's good
but I think in terms of like persuasive
click baiting it's not that good it's
not I don't know I already is it good
this one made me nervous that one got me
uh these are comments from the chat so
yeah I mean I'm just I'm seeing it but
here's the thing didn't it didn't that
one start with 12 hours because I I
think I remember yeah
I think that was cool because we're like
it's been out 12 hours
yeah you're right
but yeah I mean there's better there's
much better yeah there's better I don't
know the thing that about this is like I
don't know are we rating like the
effectiveness of the fact that the
obscenity of the clip it's a total
package right yeah I think I think
there's a lot more obscene yeah but also
how effective is it on you I think both
yeah
I think this one's a C I'm not impressed
yeah because it's not like dramatic
dramatic but it it gives people
incentive to click you know I mean wait
till you see some of these other ones
you're gonna fit in your pants the
podcast is ending I mean yeah I love
this thumbnail yeah yeah Taking It Off
the Wall that's a good thumbnail good
and what was this a reference to I so
here's the thing a lot of these were
absolutely nothing like literally just
arbitrary something no but like there
there are a handful in here that really
legitimately I remember the ones that
were nothing which was like but but this
one had to be a reference to something
I don't know let me get let me go look
real quick take take a look at what was
going on in this episode something like
you're changing a segment or maybe we
just instead off the background yeah
I'm gonna go d
it was Mom's basement ending it was this
oh good cam good that's exactly right
that's right here it is yeah I found the
section the end of the podcast that's
exactly right so it's not our podcast
it's a podcast we said the podcasters oh
so that is pretty good that's pretty
good this one's good this one's a b yeah
[Music]
maybe even a maybe a like ethically
that's correct dude that thumbnail is
just it's great yeah I'm holding the
sign we had to unscrew that and
everything yeah so let's do a yeah okay
I mean looking at the views you can tell
that it was yeah it did pretty good yeah
there you go
which rip to Mom's basement still miss
it man miss it every day
I'm going to A2 I'm sad to say that
Banks and keemstar will never speak
again it sucks I missed that podcast
dynamic duo yes I love it uh uh this one
is this one's in a d and a half
hand enlargement surgery
that's so bad that's so stupid
um this was obviously just a joke
because uh it's not even clickbait you
know it's just weird I think I threw
this idea out there's a joke and you
just you said yeah whatever we'll go
with it because we didn't have the good
title yeah and it was just the joke
about me having small hands so
it's funny though that one's a d man you
think it's D it's horrible there's
nothing clicking about it
it's deep okay no shot man that's a
that's a bottom all right bottom tier
there's literally no compelling reason
to click that
I'm gonna go down everyone's saying or S
people want this S no okay now this one
I think there was this was related to
nothing oh my God
this was [ __ ] insane
this was the uh wasn't this also another
type of enlargement surgery I had
probably was that the link
the the leg lengthening surgery oh was
this daddy long legs yeah are you sure
so that was that was this episode I'm
gonna check but I had I think that's it
yeah so we were watching
um this Doctor Who specialized in
actually making you taller two he could
add three to five inches by prolonging
your legs
so we did this we I think we just got a
stock photo
we have some operation but the Practical
this is a mix of practicality and
digital you did a great job on this one
cam well you also real you uh put
sharpie on your arm there that's real
Sharpie that's my arms that's why I was
like it looks yeah you were laying on
our table in the office yeah
yeah
scrubbing through the episode I don't
see daddy long legs in here again it was
that I remember I don't know maybe did
we talk about it before there's
something about Ace family oh maybe it
was that we were gonna do a sketch about
it I know it it was it was a um parody
of Catherine McBroom
that was I had to get emergency surgery
you're right because she had one word
was in the same like
timeline as the management yeah yeah
lots of people in the chat knew it yeah
there's somebody keep an eye on the chat
because they're probably going to get to
it before us yeah you guys can suck a
fat donut so this one wasn't effective
you can tell on the views it wasn't
super effective but it's so Shameless
and so [ __ ] good imma give it a b
yeah if it had more views I'll put it up
to an a I feel like sometimes your
clicked by thumbnails even even entice
me and like I'm inside and I know all
this stuff this would not pull me in
because I'll know you know how I know
they're good when my mom texts me or
calls me and says my mom too yeah it's
like did you even click the video they
didn't even click it it happened kind of
recently my mom was like what happened I
saw Ethan something what's funny about
these two is that they're one episode
after another and they're both surgery
related
so maybe that has
you know speaking of people falling for
clickbait my mom texts me she's all
what's going on what does Ethan do yeah
my mom Falls for every single day so we
need we need to get categories right now
yeah dude yeah we should start my mom
only called me once and actually Steve
told her to call me her boyfriend oh it
was uh I made a joke about you in the
pink shirt calling you Majin Buu and
like it was some like fan edit just
uploaded it saying that uh Ethan fires
AV for calling him fat uh lived out on
me oh my God they should just clicked
the video first they just see the title
and they freak out on my mom every time
okay so so up next we broke we broke up
this one's fire I think this is one of
the fire because the thumbnail looks so
candid it was like we looked at a bunch
of breakup videos and we like nailed
this what's funny about this video is it
starts with a sketch about us talking
about clickbait right right
and I think this one actually works
really harmoniously because we were
talking about breakup videos and videos
like this this thumb and title were fire
and you can see the views are good this
might be asked here yeah I see a lot of
people saying I got them yeah I think
it's a work of art I think this one's
asking I think that's our first test
here and the reason I think it was
awesome look at my acting yeah that
takes a lot yeah yeah to get something
to look good
and I think it was one of the first clip
dates we did so I think it was extra
effective too wow so good yeah tons of
ass it's s it's us for sure okay we got
our first s going down I'm retiring I
quit with prom alert style so this is
really interesting I got a lot of views
oh that's when keemstar said he was
going to retire oh yeah
ah
I think we just copied his whole yeah
format there just put my put me in there
yeah yeah that was the cause I love how
these episodes are all like one after
another too this is all right yeah ten
months ago the clickbait AR well that's
what I'm saying yeah there was a period
of time where we just leaned into it
heavily ruthless so the thing about this
one is I would think that people would
see it as a joke but the views are
incredible
and the I'm retiring might be very
compelling I don't know what where what
do you guys think about this one I mean
the views are throwing me off they're so
high right I mean
I guess the topic was super hot
too
yeah well let's see what happens I think
there was a controversy going on around
the Times who that might have made it
more believable that you would just like
at that point be like you know what [ __ ]
oh okay we gotta [ __ ] where's our
Halloween episode too it was around
last like fall something happened yes
[Music]
we had gotten the strike because I
pretended to be someone's girlfriend oh
we got
there was that yeah and it was like that
was coming off of a very dramatic you
know uh the thing is though it's all in
the title and thumb so people are
clicking for that I'm seeing I'm seeing
a majority be from the chat yeah yeah I
think it's a [ __ ]
yeah I probably would have rated it even
lower if the views right weren't so high
but I think B is pretty fair for this
okay I think I think we're all on the
same page yeah
this I don't know is even clickbait uh
but it's just Artistry this I remember
Ian made and I was watching him as you
made it and it's a work of art and well
what makes it click bait is the title in
conjunction with the uh Shane Dawson's
100 canceled after this wasn't this over
nothing
I think it was over now it was over
nothing but there's a clear implication
what were we thought it was his comeback
video
yeah
this [ __ ] is so funny bro
it still cracks me the [ __ ] up dude what
[Music]
yeah that's one of the best thumbnails
ever this is one for the you could frame
it on was this the origin of that
picture of you too it may have been
because we've used we went through a
long period of time where Ian was just
using that same color that same picture
of Ethan and changing the shirt color
every time
exactly well I mean in the beginning we
weren't even changing the shirt color
yeah
maybe yeah there's a lot of A's I I kind
of agree with that hey there's some s's
though it's not us it's not like it
quite raises that level I think a is
maybe Fair the view is amazing but I
think that was just a thing at the time
yeah
in the title but yeah I'm happy giving
it an a
yeah it feels fair that feels Fair
Shane's cat responds
yeah good job Ian
iconic
this one is Kim Kardashian screamed at
me in the streets of New York City we
tried our best to make it look like I
was there I don't know if it really it
was a hard it's a call order obviously
yeah it's not terrible it's not
fantastic I think cam did as good as he
possibly could yeah like
the angles are just not right you know
what I mean yeah it's not his fault
but I remember what this was mean either
we're in New York and she was staying at
the same hotel as us and we just saw her
downstairs there was like a huge mob of
we saw her out a window bro about five
seconds okay so that is pretty insane I
couldn't even see her
you didn't see her no we saw her mom
yeah no we never saw her we saw her we
saw her mom
she was there but that was it
yeah there was a like a whole Fleet of
uh
of uh what do you call those massive
SUVs Escalades Escalades rolled up
she is quite Entourage man and there was
like it was crazy it was like the
president is in town yeah like people
were gathering across from the hotel to
look out and
yeah and there's a department of
tourists there so everyone was starting
to stop there was probably like 300
people just got it was weird
ab just sent see these are after after
dark 53 54. and this is just how they
appear on the Channel I didn't combine
them or anything
they're in a row like that wait team
stars in the color block what is that
that's funny uh
I love the blue shirt purple shirt oh
okay there's three in a row actually I'm
sorry there's the fourth one I just
didn't scroll down I think that was even
more I think we were going for a while
on the channel page it's in that order
without me manipulating it okay wow
Natalie thank you for the gift dude I
want to give a shout out to my
ex-boyfriend Eric was a micro penis
shout out and he works for Texas
Instruments in Dallas
he now has started a community group for
men with micro penises funded by TI
congratulations Eric that might be a
snarky that seems relatively targeted uh
so Eric
um and Dallas
uh I'm not open about it right I'm be
proud of your micro penis he has a
massive penis shout out shout out to
Natalie s who clearly he did something
wrong to her but there it is
don't [ __ ] with with uh Natalie do not
all right so this Kim Kardashian one uh
the views are not great the views are
not great I gotta say probably the most
mixed responses I was seeing in the chat
like I think it's a B I think that
that's it's just not that convincing the
premise is not convincing I could see it
yeah I guess it's a b because of like
it's such a stretch it's such a stretch
exactly
but I could see even a seat
a c interesting
maybe it's a c
what do y'all think what's the other one
in C uh this episode will be erased in
24 hours I think it's better than that
one
I think you can see do they can see yeah
let's go see we've been to we've been
too generous all right see it is I I
guess it doesn't matter but I'd put it
as a just for the Photoshop work in
itself I mean I love the image but I
just don't think it's that I would be
I think it's just we got a lot of ground
to cover people we got to keep moving
let's keep it moving let's go let's go
all right the hardest episode I've ever
had to make wait it's only one hour what
is this
you were sick I think oh oh yeah yeah
right
not that good
that's true actually it was very true
two it's about Twitter so you just felt
like [ __ ] yeah and your throat was all
messed up or whatever so we just wrapped
it up I think it's something
to see indeed no it's a c d is the
[ __ ] dumbass big hand
it's hard to top that one
hmm I recognize this photo you guys
didn't even bother to get a new photo
we need to talk huh
good views yeah that might have been the
original one oh the OG I think I think
that it oh well it's it's a historic
artifact for that fact going on then
yeah that's 50 I think the other one
started what is it I sent it here let me
see
yeah the other one was 10 minutes 52-55.
I don't know it is maybe a c I don't
know C or B I mean the views are good
or c
it's a b it's a b then it's not it's
better than c yeah it's just the thing
is it's not that dressed up it's like
still an after dark thumbnail which
produces the seriousness of it yeah
that's true
this one's fire
finally we're releasing the DM
this one is insanely fire and I think we
played on some Frenemies thing which
obviously it was it had nothing to do
with that yeah but we tricked people and
we copied the exact thumbnail that James
Charles used for his uh taught he
response dude this one's ass bro
I think so the views are hot oh yeah The
Click bait was insane there was layers
to it the thumbnail was fire this is s
tier all the way and we got some good
memes from it we got the Govern yourself
accordingly from this oh for real that
was the DM it was the cav-cav dbms oh
that's what it was yes which has become
quite demonic yeah yeah I think you're
right and the chat largely agrees
they're they're mostly saying yeah that
one is is
the SS here yep by the way I just sent
kavcabs DMC sent me to a LA Times
Reporter so shut the [ __ ] out okay you
hear that Kev cab Ellie drive angry
ladies and gentlemen I wonder what they
could be writing about
thank you all right thank you this one's
pretty funny okay absolutely to me yes
when we were when we were pulling these
together last night this one got me
crying I was laughing so hard I I'm not
even joking I was [ __ ] dying seeing
this one again the problem with this one
is that the views are low but the click
bait and the Photoshop look awesome it's
so [ __ ] funny
uh thank you uh flim therm uh for the
100 donation uh they said 15.8 of this
for Sam's Jeep fund 20.78 for Olivia's
slave fund they're trying to get the
rest is for uh to buy a b a temporary
beard wow Sherm is uh he's one of Lena's
loyal Subs on Twitch he's a good guy
wait who his name is sherm
dogs
get thanks for the get I'm seeing mostly
A's and s's for this one it's not ass
obviously because the views are not good
I think a yeah I think it's a because
everything is working but it didn't get
the views yeah could it be
I mean that's not bad well compared to
all the other ones that's that's pretty
low the only one lower is the dumb ass
thumb [ __ ] it's a really good thumbnail
it's not bad
personally I think the thumb [ __ ] is
better than that'll be fine what I think
the thumb [ __ ] better I'm sorry
exaggerated and just [ __ ] up Wild Zach
just spread of him strike I think maybe
maybe if the black eye wasn't there it
would be a little bit right I like I
could but I like it that's the funny
element you're right though it's the
balance between real and and not but
like you have to get it right on the
money but sometimes it's so ridiculous
that you're like did he really Photoshop
a black eye so it's like either way you
win either you believe it or you don't I
think it's believable as as as some of
the other ones were we playing what was
the clickbait we were playing into on
that one uh there was a tick tock Trend
where people are being right yeah check
for corn
oh where they were like so they were
pretending to be arrested
we brought the car right we did the
sketch right right right right right
it's an A or an A B what do you guys
think I think it's an a I think it's a b
I think it's a all right a it is sorry
Zach sorry I know it's your birthday but
it's okay
this one is a D in my opinion I mean
it's funny and cool but as far as
clickbait and persuadability goes it's
got little less views what the hell is
this it's very odd because well because
we were doing the Gekko episode and at
the time most of our audience wasn't
familiar with him and so putting him in
this and having the title be taking the
channel in New Direction I'd I'd put it
Beach well just for the sake I love Lyle
I mean I love them dude yeah
this is not a criticism of uh
yeah everybody's saying D trash
I'm sorry
it's a d I'm sorry
it just is yeah it's not persuasive at
all taking the child in a New Direction
and then midlife crisis I mean like
it's a funny thumbnail but that's click
bait it's a failure I mean you're a
[ __ ] gecko it's [ __ ] hilarious I
don't know
okay this is a good one I mean this hits
the same note as art when we did yeah
that's good saying goodbye to YouTube
this is a powerful angle I gotta do more
from this spot in our house
the views are not they're mid
yeah
so I don't know maybe it's a maybe it's
an a
I guess shock with all you like worn off
or something okay yeah because I was
about to say I see that this is off the
rails number six and we haven't gotten
it to yet but there's an off the rails
number five which is like almost the
same thing really yes so this was round
two and the is it this one below yeah
yes yeah you'll see this one has great
views that one's at 2 million this one's
at 1.4 they were back to back yeah we
pushed it I think technically this one
is a better thumbnail but uh the other
one was first so I think the title on
I'm sorry Ela is the winner in the photo
on this one it's the winner of you in
the powerful place in the office I'd put
them both S2 I think
well well I'm gonna thinking this one
might be a yeah I've seen a lot of B
from the chat B it could be a b just
because the views aren't there all right
and I think I agree with that I think B
that if we go down to the
Forerunner right
I'm sorry Ela that one crushed the views
are insane but I don't think it's that
good yeah I I don't necessarily agree I
think that's a pretty good one
I agree with that the face obviously
looks silly yeah you look constipated
yeah I guess it's an a then if you guys
like that one
you know
ten more Jesus how many of these have we
done
so the last three are all just one that
we do yeah we're closer to them yeah I
don't think this really counts where did
we land on these I'm sorry the this is a
b or a b or a that one's an A and the
other one's a b yeah okay I think that's
good I don't really know why this one's
here
uh because that episode came out uh the
day after uh Frenemies had its giant
blowout episode right
so you think we just rode that I'm so
hungry like literally that like the
giant blowout where she walked out
happened and then the next day or maybe
it was two days later because we went to
the rage room yes do it with Trisha oh
yeah yeah we were gonna do it shoot in
the morning and that evening of is when
we had our fight yeah so the next
morning we went to the rage room without
her shot this and then uploaded it the
next day right so I'm guessing I think
that's pretty strong click bait okay
given the context you have to understand
the context to understand why it's such
good that all being said I still think
it's like a crb
see all the way down here because it
only really seven million views yeah but
it's only really good in the context of
knowing the history I think that you
it's Inseparable you can't take it out
of the context I'd put it to see yeah I
think I can go as high as B but that's
it you guys are being too harsh but any
other opinions on this um
no opinion
I mean I agree with both of you guys so
okay go right yeah uh I think it's let's
go see yeah
see yeah I think C
okay this one this was three weeks ago
this is the one that I got my mom
our Channel may be deleted I guess it
has a million it's only been three weeks
pretty good that's a recent one
the face is very good yeah
and it worried your mom which is
powerful
our Channel may be deleted is that when
we got our a warning yeah or a strike
or was it the opposite here let me check
I feel like it may have been I think
that was when the strike fell off yeah
that's when we lost and we were like
okay right people know it's a b maybe an
a because Eva's mom called her I'm
seeing s's I'm seeing A's a lot I don't
think it's an s
no I think because people were aware
that we were on the again context
matters in our audience I think they
were aware that we were on thin ice with
the strike situation so it was like I'm
willing to give it an a yeah it felt
real right I mean your mom called that's
pretty yeah I'm seeing a lot of A's and
s's not an S though I'll tell you that I
agree it's not an ass I think a is fair
though
I've got terrible news
this would be good if there wasn't the
h3tv background like like that kind of
ruined like a beautiful day how bad can
it be right
I think this one's a c yeah it's like
you still had time to put a nice
background behind you yeah
it's not D bad I'm not gonna disagree
but it's not great yeah same Z seems
okay this is a [ __ ] historic
clickbait
this was our show with Oliver tree whose
name still is not even in the title it
was just the Oliver tree episode
Frenemies is back in short-lived that's
kind of like an S dear I think this
might be estier yeah we we went like we
hit the do break only in case of
emergency yeah
and we you broke the glass we even
called it Frenemies number 40. yeah
they're wild yeah it's all S's in the
chat yeah it's gotta be us I had to tell
our accountant who calculates Trisha's
commission I said just so you know
number 40 is not a real credit right
all right we're almost at the end here
yeah so that's an ass that's an ass yeah
that's definitely us we finally landed
our Dream guest it's Wally P
I think this one's a d but I loved it
the other guy's too harsh it's very sad
well he does say his name constantly his
own name yeah
all right I mean I've seen a lot of
Seasons yeah okay
saddened angry without even an episode
number in it just and it's still a still
so we definitely tried hard the views
are not good dude I don't even remember
this I have no idea what this is no is
that not the hold on
oh that's not click bait I think that
was after Uvalde I'm pretty sure why the
[ __ ] would you include this oh yeah oh
my God
bro why would you include that I didn't
I thought because I mean can you blame
me for thinking it was clickbait that's
the perfect example
say it if I was wrong I was like hold on
Dan's current
I put I put all these in yeah no I I no
no he doesn't have to take all the blame
because I went through it and there were
a few that that got there were so a few
false positives in there that got a B
that I pulled out but I didn't pull this
one out do you not care about those the
what happened there I mean gee of course
I know this is just this is why you
don't clickbait because look it's the
boy who cried wolf now yeah we're not
the ones who clickbaited It Well by the
way not great views so yeah that passing
away [ __ ] yeah stop that God stop it
you're a [ __ ] demon for that
hold on it's way too soon to be joking
sorry given the past jumper brain
all right I needed to clear the air all
right there's just there's my bad let's
let's move on let's move on to admit
this ah that picture's [ __ ] awesome
oh [ __ ] not great views
I think the title's a little bit of a
stretch but the picture's so good
but yeah I mean views 1.1 not the best
no I feel like we're learning a lot
about yeah what works and what doesn't
it
it's good analysis I think the better
title for this would have been like
something about just like I can't
believe this happened or something
because I shame to admit this well what
was it based on
um
maybe oh maybe we were doing sharing
story times about the most embarrassing
oh yeah I think you're right oh yeah
because it's one year ago so that was
the crew tells embarrassing story yeah
this is this is this is I just want to
open it up I'm telling the story of me
kissing my own arm okay right okay okay
and Zach yeah shooting on the grass and
all that I say like C for this like not
the worst but not great I love the image
but the views are bad so I guess it's a
c can I can I just rewind for one second
I'm so sorry I do apologize it was too
far it's fun
it's well well words are better than
doing shut up [ __ ] over Trisha's uh
you're right yeah worse worse worse oh
definitely worse too far okay you click
the button
listen rare Zach you have qualified
immunity back there okay you know that
you're in a hazardous job sorry no yeah
I I it was just like a listen and then
there was nothing after
listen
so the next one is the last one and it's
really just a set of three and this is
kind of a bonus round because we didn't
use this oh yeah but
because we thought it was too far but
this is the funniest thumbnail that
we've ever made and it's such a shame
that it never settled this was uh making
fun of a David dobrik yeah to me this is
this would have been S Plus tier if uh
yeah we've if we actually used it yeah I
sent uh three different versions of this
as well and just oh here you go they're
in there yeah okay yeah that's the
actual phone it's Stolen Valor it ended
up being me
[Music]
good I love this one so much because I
took the original photo at the time I
was so scared of and worried how Amy
looked and now I just associate it with
this so yeah okay
better Association yeah we [ __ ] up not
using this yeah
we're talking about titling it maybe
died we could use that for this episode
this is this is the Alpha and Omega tier
this is your face off the chart well it
was up here no impression yeah that's
literally what he does yeah I mean I was
taking my tongue out say Triple S
maybe we can um
upcoming episode
I'm always on the verge of ending up in
the hospital maybe the highlight it
would have been it would have been great
for the chip yeah right that's what I'm
saying it could be the highlight I'm
gonna juice the [ __ ] out of this segment
I'm gonna do a highlights
that could be the for this segment this
could be for the Highlight yeah exactly
this thumbnail turned out really good
but I'm afraid that the title may not be
oh my God in good Synergy so maybe it's
like ELO's gone she's gone I was just
she's gone period she left me she left
is a really good she last but I cheated
and just No One Believes that yeah
that's what I'm saying it's like so
ridiculous that she left this pretty
good she left that feels like it sounds
emotional enough yeah to like possibly
be real didn't we do that that's what
I'm saying
no we never did this but he never did it
evening hold on let's do it let's throw
it to the point because I really want to
maximize here we've we've come so far
we've learned so much let's put it into
action here today I say personally with
everything I've learned here today I see
the picture and I see she left that's so
good I agree suggestions
uh oh I said she or I cheated I cheated
okay
all lower case they're saying that's
very good very good yes no after dark 65
either I gotta say I think she left is
better too to be honest
she left no punctuation no punctuation
so lowercase she left yes she I think
we're gonna do something from the chat
oh I begged her to stay okay that's
pretty decent the kids oh she took the
kids [ __ ] you know what it's like too
far it's a little gross doing good yeah
I lost her
um
and didn't get the yogurt that I wanted
okay that could be a good title Love Did
you ever something to say people say we
cut you off yeah I'm sorry I'm on a
delay so it's kind of how about no title
there is this uh like a character in uh
like Windows that that is nothing right
you can't see no
I think it would look so weird and got
YouTube suggestions
yeah I think my wife went out for pizza
without me I like the idea my wife went
out for pizza without me I mean this is
this is how our broken he was right he's
got in bed and cried
by the way I
operate a quartering and she's suing
she's suing
um I think she left is better
so just she left lower case no no period
Ela comma if you're watching
oh that is so good yo
it's kind of scary it's scary like it's
so dark oh my God
that's shocking that one might be too
much
I think that's pretty good they call us
in the chat that all right let's let's
throw it to a poll I feel like we have a
good one a lot of good ones she left
here I'm gonna use our new poll oh we
have a new polling technology new
polling technology because it allows us
to have more than four options which we
definitely have more than four here also
you'll be able to see it on screen right
yes indeed that's pretty exciting we
heard the feedback from the fupa
Troopers that the YouTube polls do not
show in the replay
okay we're gonna put it on screen so he
left so title
she left all all lower case no
punctuation uh-huh Ela if you're
watching you look comma if you want so
no no no punctuation I'll lower case
just one comma right okay no period got
it
um the blank no titles that's nothing
I think I like that idea but for a
different video
no thing
well let's included let's include it
okay just nothing nothing just nothing
can be fun to do like a black screen
sometime in the future too and nothing
yeah I don't think that works we people
have tried that [ __ ] I think the YouTube
doesn't like those videos I just want
everyone to keep in mind this is one
time where the cheating thing would
actually make sense because of young
gravy so yeah just keep that in mind
well it's all there the DNA is all here
[Music]
instead of something that like blank or
something we can do that we could
definitely do that but I'm suggesting it
another time right yeah people are
suggesting just the date well hold on
today's date oh the date that's [ __ ]
gnarly a code like XX again these are
all good these can be used at any time
by the way love if you want to try it on
the Highlight shuttle that could be
interesting to see if like the dot or
the nothing or the black on black you
know what I mean all right what a
powerful weapon well you can get you can
get a small sample there and see but you
might actually be right though Ethan
YouTube might like just hardcore
suppress that they do if it's just black
and no title they don't they don't yeah
I probably won't suggest it they don't
want that in their on their home page
and sidebar last episode ruined my
marriage guys I'm not gonna do anything
with the kids yeah
I missed Theo someone said I was like
are you no no no no dear Ela
dear Ela that's good like a dress to her
that feels like he killed me
right do you guys get that vibe
another one I think people oh the the
years of your marriage
2013 to 2022. we almost made it
we almost made it to a decade or
something
first of all I don't want to click bait
uh anyone dying the best almost 10 years
of my life again that's like dying [ __ ]
oh people saying uh yeah the file name
that's always a good one something like
09-2-3-2022.mp4 oh combine those two oh
that was from C CU Maui or whatever the
[ __ ] dot MP4 okay yeah that's a good one
that's great okay
so we have one two three four five
options so far
someone said Ela please watch
she found out
she found out
please forgive me
Kayla come home
Ela come home is good
Ela come home is crazy it's over
you guys have good ideas
people like you look we're up to eight
options here all right I think that's a
lot yeah let's run it
okay so stand by now this we got all
kinds of fancy stuff
I can allow people to select multiple
options so they don't have to pick just
one they can pick
one they think is good let them pick uh
two options I don't I think it's either
or it's either like you pick all the
ones it's like you can pick as many as
you want you wanna do that yeah
oh wait no it does exact number two
there it is you guys get hey so you got
two choices oh that's so cool two
two two
okay uh stand by one vote per IP address
all right everybody get your votes in uh
this is important
and I'm going to
uh
uh Lair it said it's over but I think we
that's in there isn't there I feel like
it's or something similar a title that's
just like Ela that would get a lot of
attention all right well the polls made
so just Ela yeah a suggestion uh from
busytube I felt gay
I felt worth
I felt ugly
I felt gay I felt that no like that they
told me all right here's the poll Dude
that [ __ ] the fourth part of that is
so funny it's just stumbling over it oh
[ __ ] dude what the [ __ ] wait we're doing
straw polls that's that's not even
integrated
that's it is integrated watch really how
is it because we set up a whole thing
that uh oh wow Ian's gonna be able to
put this on screen
it's it's it says 404 uh I'm not sure
what that I'm afraid
uh wait how is it integrated it's just a
link in chat no it shows on it's just
gonna go on screen on something this is
this is groundbreaking okay okay because
you I could just pull it up on the
browser work with me
I mean it's not that much better than
just opening the browser is it okay but
now people covering ela's head
[Music]
it's not as simple as you think it is
it's fairly simple but but
point is is that now when people watch
this later they can actually see it open
the browser you
that way have fun go ahead but this is
pretty cool yeah I mean what's
discovering your head okay well like I'm
not it can be moved I'm not I'm not
arguing I'm not trying to like I'm not
trying to say it was bad I'm just saying
it's not that though it looks pretty I
will take it off the overlay
there you go now you open it right there
fade it out there you go
way more fancy it gives us all of these
options I want it back I didn't say
remove it I just said I just I was just
being
I was just being a little catty dude
yeah it's a good overlay
it's pretty good so people are liking
this is interesting because
what was the one that everyone was
liking before she left
or she found out uh um yeah she left was
the one and then that and then Nicholas
came out with the Banger
you know if you're watching is
dominating and I mean yeah
[ __ ] that one is so intense
that's it let's change the title watch
our views go up immediately you'll be
playing with like
fire like this is like too much like
people are gonna think something
happened to me you know I went missing
um yeah maybe but unfortunately to find
out yeah we've come way too far for that
hair enough they'll click listen it's
not even up to us the people have voted
overwhelmingly for ELA if you're
watching just so you understand this
election was a fraud
the Third rated is the dot MP4 because I
feel like that's kind of like outdated
Eva if you're watching here it is what
do you think
that's like last season of clickbait
yeah I feel that look at this [ __ ]
that's good that's good we need to see
it like that that's [ __ ] insane
that's messed up I feel like that's like
the beginning of an episode on uh
Dateline yo yeah that's the title of the
episode Ela if you're watching
it all started in a small suburb of Los
Angeles
this husband calls the police
apparently the wife is gone we've
utilized an incredible power here I feel
like a what was the name of that guy
who's like I become death in the perfect
placement Oppenheimer thanks bro awesome
placement wait we didn't even see the
whole [ __ ] thing Ian why is he crop
like that you put it over my face like
are you trying to do a joke I'm just
done you can't even see the pole but did
you see the fade
well there was a fade yeah that was dope
since we covered your face we could
title the episode Ethan went missing
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
destroyer of worlds I feel that we've
gained that level of Power by harnessing
the chat or clickbait title I believe
that's a quote from the Hindu uh like
about Gita there you go okay
okay Cam W cam
I think maybe we should do this at the
end of every episode though make a
tradition maybe not it's too much to do
all the time I don't know it's powerful
it's like
people say they don't want nuclear uh
power plants because oh it's too much
but they're what we've fished [ __ ] is
that their argument that's too much
I believe the individual citizen in this
country has a right to own a nuclear war
exactly
all right that's it I think I think we
can put a lid on this episode yeah I
think so
we've done well we've come so far well
wow what a special treasure of a day
here with Seaman yeah I love the quality
man such a character man that guy is one
of a kind
uh we had a great time with the click
bait and uh well we have a lot
I'm a fan oh yeah we had a lot of stuff
left over like there's this great
segment we had
I never I missed this this is the meme
history it's a reoccurring segment we're
gonna do the great Howie Mandel hostage
conspiracy of Summer 2020. loved it I
didn't know anything about this but
we'll save it for next week okay also
the FDA warns about using NyQuil to cook
chicken Ila
people do that people are using NyQuil
to cook chicken
apparently it's a
we'll get into it
anyway guys have a fantastic weekend we
love you
and we'll be back Monday for another
week of shows so
peace and love peace and love
this is a serious message if you are
using NyQuil to cook your chicken please
no more NyQuil thank you thank you
yeah all right anytime you guys
where's the music
anytime
even shout out to my family Ethan a b
cam Dan he Ela Ian Lena Olivia Sam Zach
now